all right guys unless you're pool we
need to leave the room please unless
your designated pool we need to exit the
room thank you
we are doing the cut thing
so you're the one staying
okay
welcome everybody to today's hybrid
hearing
pursuant to house rules some members
will appear in person and others will
appear remotely via zoom
for members appearing remotely i know
you are all familiar with zoom by now
but let me remind you
first the house rules require that we
see you
so please have your cameras turned on at
all times
second members appearing remotely who
are not recognized should remain muted
to minimize background noise
third i will recognize members verbally
but members retain the right to seek
recognition verbally in regular order
lastly if you want to be recognized
outside of regular order you may
identify that in several ways you may
use the chat function to send a request
you may send an email to the majority
staff or you may unmute your mic to seek
recognition we will begin the hearing in
just a moment when they tell us they are
ready to begin the live stream
the committee will come to order
without objection the chair is
authorized to declare recess of the
committee at any time
i now recognize myself for an opening
statement
today we will examine the destruction
and heartbreak
that gun violence is causing across our
country
i want to express my deep gratitude
to each of our witnesses for being here
today
i am particularly grateful to our
witnesses who will be discussing
the loss of their loved ones
and their personal experiences from
recent mass shootings in uvalde texas
and buffalo new york
despite their pain these witnesses
express their strong desire
to share their stories with this
committee and the public
i know that i speak for every member of
this committee when i say that we are
inspired by your bravery
for a parent there is no greater pain
than the loss of a child
but across the country senseless gun
violence is claiming the lives of our
children and loved ones in places where
they should be safe
our schools
our supermarkets
even our churches and our synagogues
gun violence
is the leading cause of death
for children in our country
as a society we are failing our children
and we are failing each other
this out of control gun violence is a
uniquely american tragedy
as you can see in this chart
in 2019 united states
suffered 17 times more gun deaths than
the next highest g7 country
we stand alone
in mass shootings
other countries pass sensible gun safety
laws and protect children
and no other country comes close
to the number of school shootings we
have
between 2009 and 2018 the u.s had
288
288
school shootings
all other g7 countries
had just five
some of my colleagues on across the
aisle have blamed the violence on mental
illness
they have blamed violent video games
they have blamed family values
they have even blamed open doors
they have blamed everything
but guns
but we know the united states does not
have a monopoly on mental illness video
games or any other excuse
what america does have
is widespread access
to
guns that includes assault weapons which
were designed to kill as many
enemy soldiers on the battlefield as
possible as quickly as possible
yet in many states these weapons of war
can be purchased by an 18 year old just
by walking into a store
assault weapons were used in the recent
massacres
in buffalo texas and tulsa
just as they were in parkland newtown
san bernardino orlando las vegas and so
many other mass shootings
these weapons have no place in our
communities
no civilian needs an assault rifle
and the second amendment does not
protect the right to own a weapon of war
it's time that we banned assault rifles
from our streets from our communities
from our homes
but if we are going to truly address the
gun crisis we need to be honest
about why our country has failed to act
sooner
the truth is the gun industry is making
billions of dollars
selling the weapons that are killing our
children
and they are fighting tooth and nail to
keep doing it
that is why i have launched an
investigation into five leading gun
manufacturers that sell assault weapons
used in mass shootings
we need to know why these communities
are marketing military weapons to
civilians and how much they are
profiting from the death of our children
of course mass shootings are just one
part of this crisis
we can't forget that gun violence is a
steady drum beat in so many of our towns
and cities especially in marginalized
communities
black men make up more than half of all
gun victims in the united states
despite making up less than six percent
of the population
latinos are twice as likely to be killed
by a gun and four times as likely to be
wounded by a gun as white americans
we need transparency into how guns are
reaching the hands of criminals
which is why this committee has been
working to identify the gun dealers that
are selling the most guns used in crimes
including across state lines
today the house is voting to pass common
sense gun safety legislation
which is a crucial first step in
addressing this crisis
i am particularly grateful this bill
will include key provisions similar to a
bipartisan bill i first introduced more
than 10 years ago
with a strong support of former chairman
elijah cummings
my bill will make gun trafficking a
federal felony and strengthen penalties
for straw purchasers
which will help stop the flow of guns
into the hands of criminals
my goal for today's hearing is simple
i am asking every member of this
committee
to listen with an open heart to the
brave witnesses who have come forward to
tell their stories about how gun
violence has impacted their lives
our witnesses today have endured pain
and loss
yet they are displaying incredible
courage by coming here to ask us to do
our jobs
let us hear their voices let us honor
their courage let us find the same
courage to pass common sense laws to
protect our children
i now recognize the distinguished
ranking member mr comer for an opening
statement
thank you chairwoman maloney and
all of our hearts go out to the victims
and the families in uvalde texas in
buffalo new york
to those who are testifying before us
today there are no words to describe the
horror you have faced and the deep
anguish you feel
the american people grieve with you
as elected representatives in congress
it's our obligation to work to ensure
that these violent crimes and tragedies
never happen again
americans of all backgrounds
should be empowered to defend themselves
against rising violence
the increased violence we have witnessed
since the summer of 2020 is unacceptable
murders and aggravated assaults are all
up
this is a trend
we must reverse
we have recently witnessed several
high-profile
senseless acts of murder and mayhem that
have impacted all americans
including tragically our defenseless and
innocent school children
we must respond to those hideous acts
and provide justice for the families
at the same time
we recognize that violence occurs in
many of our communities on a daily basis
impacting americans across the united
states from every background
too often tragedies are politicized for
partisan gain and we have seen many seek
to leverage these crimes and their
victims to push for radical left-wing
policies or to betress their campaigns
to get elected
instead of rushing to score political
points at the expense of our justice
system working properly we must learn
from these senseless acts of violence
and take concrete action
to reduce violence in the future
we owe it to the families
of the victims
they deserve justice
and we owe it to the american people
we must and can prevent similar
tragedies we all want to live in a
country where we can achieve
our american dream without the threat of
violence in our communities
we must work together
to deliver sensible solutions to secure
our schools
protect our most vulnerable among us
and bring to justice those responsible
for these heinous crimes
our local officials cannot defund our
police
and our prosecutors cannot be soft on
crime
i believe that we must carefully
consider the security posture of
vulnerable targets sought out
by evil people
we must ensure that every american has a
safe environment in which to live their
lives in peace
and that requires thinking creatively
about solutions to harden our
infrastructure enforce our existing laws
and work to foster a culture that values
conflict resolution and dialogue over
violence
i strongly believe that there is
important place
for law abiding gun owners to serve in
protecting themselves
their families and their communities
from violence
our second amendment is an important
tool in securing our individual rights
to self-defense
knee-jerk reactions to impose gun
control policies that seek to curtail
our constitutional right to bear arms
are not the answer
gun ownership is on the rise in america
people want to protect themselves and
their families
we should commend all law-abiding gun
owners who safely use store
and carry those firearms not vilify them
for blatantly political purposes
i also believe we must continue to
empower our law enforcement
professionals to serve and protect our
communities honorably
as i said before
defund the police and soft on crime
prosecution policies have been a failure
across the board
efforts to divert violent criminals out
of the criminal justice system have
failed leading to the victimization of
the very communities those policies were
promised to help
violent criminals should be in jail
not back on the streets to reoffend
and terrorize
we must recommit ourselves to pursuing
justice and keeping violent criminals
off our street
thank you chairman maloney and i yield
back
the gentleman yields back i want to
clarify that i support the second
amendment i support law-abiding
gun owners i don't support
lax gun laws that allow guns to get into
the hands of criminals and unstable
people i now recognize a gentlelady from
california miss porter for an opening
statement
i represent a community in mourning
less than one month ago in laguna woods
a gunman locked the doors to the geneva
presbyterian church and opened fire on
my community's tight-knit taiwanese
congregation
this shooting was an undeniable tragedy
but under different circumstances it
could have been an unimaginable massacre
unlike the shooters in uvalde and
buffalo the shooter in laguna woods did
not carry an assault rifle equipped with
high capacity magazines he was armed
with nine millimeter handguns that
forced him to reload
that difference gave a hero dr john
cheng a chance to stop the carnage he
sacrificed his life to stop the shooter
and his
bravery was remarkable but we cannot
depend on a hero's bravery to save lives
law enforcement has determined that the
gunman was ready to kill every person in
the church
had he been armed with a military-style
assault rifle he may have done so there
is no telling how many more lives would
have been lost
shootings involving assault weapons are
six times
as deadly as shootings involving
handguns and when assault weapons are
equipped with high-capacity magazines or
bump stocks the death toll rises even
further
california has banned these weapons for
years our laws have saved lives
including members of geneva presbyterian
church
congress must follow californians lead
i yield back
the lady yields back i now recognize the
gentleman from louisiana mr higgins for
an opening statement thank you madam
chair it's a sober day
in congress
as we reflect upon the challenges our
nation faces
in 2005 as a young cop
i was dispatched to reports of a man
down in the street
in part of the city that was crime
ridden and dangerous
i found a victim
a teenager and
i held the mortal wound
in the back of his head
whispered prayer into his ear
as his life flowed
from his body
he died there in my arms
on the street
he was killed by an axe handle
i am prayerful for america i'm prayerful
for healing
and i'm prayerful for discernment
amongst this body and my colleagues as a
law enforcement officer i know what it
means to swear an oath
to protect and serve my community and my
nation and the importance
of bringing justice to the families of
those who suffer at the hands of evil
and it is essential that the fundamental
freedoms first amendment second
amendment fourth amendment
are always protected and preserved by
this body
i was
sworn
as a man
i sworn oath to uphold the constitution
of the united states and i will never
back down from defending that
constitution including the rights of
law-abiding americans
to keep and bear arms
madam chair i thank you for this hearing
today and i yield
the gentleman yields now we will
introduce our witnesses i'd like to turn
it over to the gentleman from new york
mr higgins to introduce our first
witness without objection mr higgins is
authorized to participate in today's
hearing he represents buffalo and you
are now recognized mr higgins
thank you madam chair and
ranking member the honorable members of
the
oversight and reform committee
the
greek tragic poet
escolus
says that we suffer our way to wisdom
he says we suffer our way to wisdom to
live is to suffer to endure the
suffering
is to give meaning
to the suffering
we have a problem in this country unless
we learn
from the tragic events of the last three
weeks
who are we
as a people
and this brave group of panelists
from two cities that were devastated
a destruction beyond human comprehension
we have to find a way to deal with this
in buffalo
the shooting started
at 2 30 in the afternoon and was
concluded
in two minutes
and three seconds
one shooter
a semi-automatic weapon
13 people shot
10 dead
one shooter if you look for a common
denominator in all of these it's
typically
someone that should never have had a gun
with a high capacity weapon
to kill as many as people as many people
as quickly as possible
zaneta everhart is here
she is a friend
and a proud citizen
of the city of buffalo
zanetta
is with us today
as the mother of a buffalo mass shooting
survivor zaire goodman
zaire was working at the tops friendly
market
that was targeted by a white supremacist
racist
deranged
gunman
zaire is also a colleague of gov in
government
she is director of diversity and
inclusion for my friend and colleague
new york state senator tim kennedy
zanetta's
story
is both tragic and magic
and with that it gives me great
honor
to present to the committee zaneta
everhart
thank you and after ms everhart we will
hear from dr roy guerrero who is a
pediatrician in uvalde
texas
uh then we will hear from
mia cerrillo who is a fourth grader at
robb elementary school
in texas mia will be sharing her
experience in a pre-recorded video
her father miguel is with us in the room
today and will be making brief remarks
after his daughter's video then he will
excuse himself next we will hear from
felix and kimberly rubio who are the
parents of lexi rubio who tragically
lost her life in the texas shooting i
now recognize the gentleman from georgia
mr heist to introduce our last witness
on this panel
thank you madam chair it's my
honor to recognize lucretia hughes she
is a
part of
my constituency
an incredibly bright light in our
10th district and
she has an extremely
compelling story i just wanted to
publicly recognize
lucretia i want to thank you for being
here today
i know it's
hard to share the story that you come to
us with but we are grateful that you're
here and i just uh madam chair i want to
say thank you
for just these few uh seconds to
recognize lucretia hughes and welcome
her here
thank you the witnesses will be unmuted
so we can swear them in
please raise your right hands
do you swear or affirm that the
testimony you are about to give is the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth so help you god
thank
you let the record show that the
witnesses answered in the affirmative
thank you and without objection your
written statements will be made part of
the record with that
ms everhart you are now recognized for
your testimony
please testify ms everhart
thank you
chairwoman
zaire my son goodman my son or as i like
to call him the kid
was shot and injured by a domestic
terrorist on saturday may 14 2022 at the
top's grocery store where he was an
employee in a historically black
community on jefferson avenue in buffalo
new york
zaire the kid is now a 21 year old man
he's pure joy he's everything that is
good in this world
and as i sit here before you today
i can hear my son telling me
to stop being extra and get to the point
i was going to tell you all a bunch of
fluffy funny stories about zaire
um
but i have
i have a message
so i'll get to the point
as director of diversity and inclusion
with new york state senator tim
kennedy's office stories of gun violence
and racism are all too familiar
but now these stories are zaire's
stories
these problems literally knocked on my
front door
these are issues that as a country we do
not like to openly discuss
domestic terrorism exists in this
country for three reasons
america is inherently violent
this is who we are as a nation the very
existence of this country was founded on
violence hate and racism with the near
annihilation of my native brothers and
sisters
my ancestors brought to america through
the slave trade were the first currency
of america
let me say that again for the people in
the back
my ancestors the first currency of
america were stripped of their heritage
and culture separated from their
families bargained for or auction blocks
sold being raped and lynched yet i
continuously hear after every mass
shooting that this is not who we are as
americans and as a nation
hear me clearly
this is exactly who we are
education
majority of what i have learned about
african american history i did not learn
until i went to college and i had to
choose those classes
why is that why is african american
history not a part of american history
african americans built this country
from the ground up my ancestors blood is
embedded in the soil
we have to change the curriculum in
schools across the country so that we
may adequately educate our children
reading about history is crucial to the
future of this country learning about
other cultures ethnicities and religions
in schools should not be something that
is up for debate
we cannot continue to whitewash
education creating generations of
children to believe that one race of
people are better than the other
our differences should make us curious
not angry at the end of the day i bleed
you bleed we are all human
that awful day that will now be a part
of the history books hopefully
let us not forget to add that horrific
day to the curriculum that we teach our
children
guns
the 18 year old terrorists who stormed
into my community armed with an ar-15
killing 10 people and injuring three
others received the shotgun from his
parents for his 16th birthday
for zaire's 16th birthday i bought him a
few video games some headphones a pizza
and a cake
we are not the same
how and why
and what in the world is wrong with this
country
children should not be armed with
weapons parents who provide their
children with guns should be held
accountable lawmakers who continuously
allow these mass shootings to continue
by not passing stricter gun laws should
be voted out
to the lawmakers who feel that we do not
need stricter gun laws let me paint a
picture for you
my son zaire has a hole in the right
side of his neck
two on his back and another on his left
leg
caused by an exploding bullet from an
ar-15
as i clean his wounds i can feel pieces
of that bullet in his back shrapnel will
be left inside of his body for the rest
of his life
now i want you to picture that exact
scenario for one of your children
this should not be your story
or mines
as an elected official it is your duty
to draft legislation that protects zaire
and all of the children and citizens in
this country common sense gun laws are
not about your personal feelings or
beliefs you are elected because you have
been chosen and are trusted to protect
us but let me say to you here today i do
not feel protected
no citizen needs an ar-15 these weapons
are designed to do the most harm in the
least amount of time and on saturday may
14th it took a domestic terrorist just
two minutes to shoot and kill 10 people
and injure three others if after hearing
from me and the other people testifying
here today does not move you to act on
gun laws i invite you to my home to help
me clean zyre's wounds so that you may
see up close the damage that has been
caused to my son and to my community
to the families of ruth whitfield pearl
young catherine massey hayward patterson
celestine cheney geraldine talley aaron
salter andre mcneil marcus morrison and
roberta drury
i promise that their deaths will not be
in vain zaire and i promise to use our
voice to lift their names and we will
carry their spirit with us as we embark
on this journey to create change i know
that their collective souls watched out
for zaire that day and i am eternally
grateful to them for that
to the east side of buffalo i love you
i'm speaking directly to my people to my
hood
from bailey to broadway to kensington to
fillmore to delavan to jefferson and
every street in between
just like the potholes that we want
filled in yes i keep it real together we
will continue to fill those streets with
love
no matter what people say about the east
side of buffalo we will not be broken
i was born there raised there
i raised my son there i still live there
and i do the majority of my professional
work on the east side of buffalo i vow
to you today that everywhere i go i will
make sure that the people hear the real
stories of our people for too long our
community has been neglected and starved
of the resources that we so greatly need
i promise that i will not stop pushing
for more resources to be funneled into
the east side of buffalo each and every
person that lives within that community
we are family not a perfect community
but i know that we are love
to the greater buffalo area to everyone
from around the country and the world
who have reached out and loved on us
on behalf of zaire zaire's father damian
goodman my mother my father my sisters
my brothers
and myself we thank you
we thank you for all of your thoughts
and your prayers thank you for all of
the love and support you have shown us
during this difficult time
but i also say to you today with a heart
full from the outpouring of love that
you also freely gave us
your thoughts and prayers
are not enough
we need you to stand with us in the days
weeks months and years to come and be
ready to go to work and help us to
create the change that this country so
desperately needs and i will end with a
quote
from charles bloom
in his book the devil we know
race as we have come to understand it is
a fiction but racism as we have come to
live it is a fact
the point here is not to impose a new
racial hierarchy but to remove an
existing one
after centuries of waiting for white
majorities to overturn white supremacy
it is to me that it has fallen to black
people to do it themselves and i stand
at the ready
zaire
this is for you kid happy birthday
thank you
uh dr guerrero you are now recognized
for your testimony
thank you
thank you chairwoman
my name is dr roy guerrero i'm a
board-certified pediatrician and was
present at you valley memorial hospital
the day of the massacre on may 24 2022
at robb elementary school
i was called here today as a witness but
i showed up
because i am a doctor
because how many years ago i swore an
oath
and oath to do no harm
after witnessing firsthand the carnage
in my hometown of uvalde
to stay silent would have betrayed that
oath
inaction is harm
passivity is harm
delay is harm
so here i am not to plead
not to beg or convince you of anything
but to do my job and hope that by doing
so it inspires the members of this house
to do theirs
i've lived in yuvaldi my whole life
in fact i attended rob elementary school
myself as a kid
as often as the case with us grown-ups
we remember a lot of the good and not so
much of the bad
so i don't recall homework or detention
remember how much i loved going to
school
what a joyful time it was
back then we were able to run between
classrooms with ease to visit our
friends
and i remember the way the cafeteria
smelled at lunchtime on hamburger
thursdays
it was right around lunchtime on a
tuesday that the gunman entered the
school through a main door without
restriction
massacred 19 students and two teachers
and changed the way that every student
at rob and their family will remember
that school forever
i doubt they remember the smell of the
cafeteria or the laughter ringing in the
hallways
instead they'll be haunted by the memory
of screams and bloodshed panic and chaos
police shouting parents wailing i know
will never forget what i saw that day
for me that day started like any typical
tuesday in our pediatric clinic moms
calling for coughs boogers sports
physicals
right before the summer rush
school was out in two days then summer
camps would guarantee some grazes and
ankle sprains
injuries that could be patched up and
fixed with a mickey mouse sticker as a
reward
then at 12 30 business as usual stopped
and with it my heart
a colleague from a san antonio trauma
center texted me and said
why are pediatric surgeons
anesthesiologists on call for a mass
shooting in uvalde
i raced to the hospital to find parents
outside yelling children's names in
desperation
and sobbing as they beg for any news
related to their child
those mothers cries i will never get out
of my head
as i entered the chaos of the er i the
first casualty i came across was mia
she was sitting in the hallway her face
was still
still clearly in shock but her whole
body was shaking from the adrenaline
coursing through it
the white lilo and shirt that she wore
was covered in blood
and her shoulder was bleeding from a
shrapnel injury
sweet mia i've known her my whole life
as a baby she survived major liver
surgeries against all odds
and once again she's here
as a survivor
inspiring us with her with her story
today and her bravery
when i saw mia sitting there i
remembered having seen her parents
outside
so after quickly examining two other
patients of mine in the hallway with
minor injuries i raced outside to let
them know that mia was alive
i wasn't ready for their next urgent and
desperate question
where's elena elena is me his
eight-year-old sister who was also at
rob at the time of the shooting
i had heard from some of the nurses that
there were two dead children who had
been moved to the surgical area of the
hospital
as i made my way there i prayed that i
wouldn't find her
i didn't find elena
but what i did find was something no
prayer will ever relieve
two children whose bodies have been
pulverized by bullets fired at them
decapitated
whose flesh had been ripped apart
that the only clue at their identities
was a blood splattered cartoon clothes
still clinging to them
clinging for life and finding none
i could only hope these two bodies were
a tragic exception to the list of
survivors
but as i waited there with my fellow
uvalde doctors nurses first responders
and hospital staff for other casualties
we hoped to save
they never arrived
all that remained was the bodies of 17
more children and the two teachers who
cared for them who dedicated their
careers to nurturing and respecting the
awesome potential every single one
just as we doctors do
i'll tell you why i became a
pediatrician because i knew that
children were the best patients they
accept the situation as it's explained
to them
you don't have to coax them into
changing their lifestyles in order to
get better or plead them to modify their
behavior as you do with adults
no matter how hard you try to help an
adult their path to healing is always
determined by how willing they are to
take action
adults are stubborn
we're resistant to change even when the
change will make things better for
ourselves
but especially when we think we're
immune to the fallout
why else would have been such little
progress made in congress to stop gun
violence
innocent children all over the country
today are dead because laws and policy
allows people to buy weapons before
they're legally old enough to even buy a
pack of beer
they're dead because restrictions have
been allowed to lapse they're dead
because there are no rules about where
guns are kept because no one is paying
attention to who is buying them
the thing i can't figure out is whether
our politicians are failing us out of
stubbornness
passivity or both
i said before that as grown-ups we have
a convenient habit remembering the good
and forgetting the bad
never more so that when it comes to our
guns
once the blood is rinsed away from the
bodies of our loved ones and scrubbed
off the floors of the schools and
supermarkets and churches the carnage
from each scene is erased from our
collective conscience and we return
again to nostalgia
to the rose into the view of our second
amendment as a perfect instrument of
american life
no matter how many lives are lost
i chose to be a pediatrician i chose to
take care of children
keeping them safe from preventable
diseases i can do
keeping them safe from bacterial and
brittle bones i can do
but making sure our children are safe
from guns
that's the job of our politicians and
leaders
in this case you are the doctors
and our country is a patient we are
lying on the operating table reeled with
bullets like the children of robb
elementary and so many other schools we
are bleeding out and you are not there
my oath as a doctor means that i signed
up to save lives i do my job
and i guess it turns out that i am here
to plead to beg
to please please
do yours
thank you
we will now play the video from mia
as an entry
um
and then she got an email
and then
she went to go lock the door and he was
in the hallway
and they made eye contact
and then she went
back in the room
go hide
and then we went to go
hide behind my teacher's desk and
behind
the backpacks
and
then he shot the little window
and then he went to the other classroom
and then he went
there's a door between our classrooms
and he went to there
and saw my teacher and told my teacher
good night and shot her in the head
and then he shot
some of my classmates
and the white board
when i went to the backpacks uh
he shot my friend that was next to me
and i
thought he was gonna come back to the
room so i grabbed the blood
and
i put it all over me
and
what did you do then when you put the
blood on yourself
just stay quiet and then i got my
teacher's phone
and calm
down are you telling anyone now i told
her that we need help
and
to sit in the police
in the in our classroom
if there was something that you want
people to know about
that day and about you right
or things that you want different what
would it be
to have security
do you feel safe at school
why not
because i don't want it to happen again
do you think it's gonna happen again
mr surya you're now acting recognized
hello
hello today
i come
because that girl lost my baby girl
she's not the same little girl that i
used to play with hang around with
and do everything because she was
daddy's little girl
i have five kids and she's a middle
child
i don't know what to do because i think
i would have lost my baby girl
my baby girl is the world not only once
but twice
she came back to us
she's everything
not only for me but her siblings and her
mother
i thank you for letting me be here and
speak out but i wish something will
change not only for our kids
but every single kid in the world
because schools are not safe anymore
something needs to really change
thank you
thank you for your testimony and i
understand you are now leaving we thank
you for sharing your story
thank you and and mr and mrs rubio you
are now recognized for your testimony
i am kimberly rubio this is felix rubio
we're the parents of alexandria anaya
best known as lexi rubio and five other
children
who all attended yuvaldi public schools
during the 2021-2022 school year
calista who completed high school this
year
isaiah who attends yuvaldi high school
david morales junior high
jalila flores elementary and our two
youngest children julian 8 and lexi 10
who were at rob elementary
on the morning of may 24 2022 i dropped
lexi and julian off at school
a little after seven a.m
my husband and i returned to the campus
at 8 am for julian's award ceremony and
again at 10 30 a.m for lexi's award
ceremony
lexi received the good citizen award and
was also recognized for receiving all
a's
at the conclusion of the ceremony we
took photos with her before asking her
to pose for a picture with her teacher
mr reyes
that photo her last photo
ever was taken at approximately 10 54
a.m
to celebrate
we promised to get her ice cream that
evening
i told her we loved her and we would
pick her up after school
i can still see her walking with us
toward the exit
in the real that keeps scrolling across
my memories she turns her head and
smiles back at us to acknowledge my
promise
and then we left
i left my daughter at that school
and that decision will haunt me for the
rest of my life
afterward felix dropped me off at my
office the audi leader
news returned home because it was a rare
day off for him between normal shifts
and security gigs he takes to help make
ends meet
i got situated at my desk and began
writing about a new business in town
when the news office started hearing
commotion on the police scanner
a shooting on dia street near rob
elementary
it wasn't long before we received word
from my son's teacher that they were
safe secure in the classroom
once evacuated from campus the children
were reunited with parents and guardians
of the civic center
my dad picked up julian from the civic
center and took him to my grandmother's
house
one of our rob kids was safe
we focused on finding lexie
bus after bus arrived but she wasn't on
board
we heard there were children at the
local hospital so we drove over to
provide her description
she wasn't there
my dad drove an hour and a half to san
antonio to check with university
hospital
at this point some part of me must have
realized that she was gone
in the midst of chaos i had the urge to
return to rob
we didn't have our car at this point
traffic was everywhere
so i ran i ran barefoot with my flimsy
sandals in my hand
i ran a mile to the school my husband
with me
we sat outside for a while before it
became clear we wouldn't receive an
answer from law enforcement on scene
san antonio firefighter eventually gave
us a ride back to the civic center where
the district was asking all families who
had not been reunited with their
children together
soon after we received the news that our
daughter was among the 19 students and
two teachers that died as a result of
gun violence
we don't want you to think of lexi as
just a number
she was intelligent
compassionate and athletic
she was quiet
shy unless she had a point to make
she knew she was right she so often was
she stood her ground
she was firm direct voice unwavering
so today
we stand for lexi
and as her voice we demand action
we seek a ban on assault rifles and
high-capacity magazines
we understand that for some reason
to some people
to people with money to people who fund
political campaigns
the guns are more important than
children
so at this moment
we ask for progress
we seek
to raise the age to purchase these
weapons from 18 to 21 years of age we
seek red flag laws
stronger background checks
we also want to repeal gun manufacturers
liability and unity
you've all seen glimpses of who lexi was
but i also want to tell you a little bit
about who she would have been
if given the opportunity
lexi would have made a positive change
in this world
she wanted to attend st mary's
university in san antonio texas on a
softball scholarship
she wanted to major in math and go on to
attend law school
that opportunity was taken from her
she was taken from us
i'm a reporter
a student a mom a runner
i've read to my children since they were
in the womb
my husband is a law enforcement officer
an iraq war veteran
he loves fishing and our babies
somewhere out there there's a mom
listening to our testimony
thinking i can't even imagine their pain
not knowing that our reality
will one day be hers
unless we act now
thank you for your time
thank you for your testimony
ms hughes you are now recognized for
your testimony
honorable chairwoman maloney rankin
member comer
distinguished members of the committee
thank you for allowing me to be here
today to address the violence in our
country my name is lucretia hughes
kluken i have four children and nine
grandchildren on the night of april the
second 2016
my family got a phone call that would
change our lives forever
my ex husband answered the phone and let
out a blood curdling scream
a scream of pain from the depths of his
soul
he screamed he'd cry he's gone he is
gone
our 19 year old son emmanuel
went to a party early that night
after we got the call we was frantic we
called his phone no one answered
we called even the police
i went to facebook and i had to ask is
my son dead
i found out that he was shot point blake
in the head and killed while playing
dominoes
no one spoke up for weeks
and the killer was on the run
no one was going to snitch
but that is the street life
words can't describe how hard it is to
bury a child
i ate for anyone and all who have done
the same
my son death was a result of a criminal
with an evil heart
and a justice system failing to hold him
accountable for the laws he had already
broken
you see
a convicted felon killed my son
with an illegally obtained gun
our gun control lobbyists and
politicians claim that their policies
will save lives and reduce violence
well those policies did not save my son
the laws being discussed are already
implemented
in cities across this country
we have decades of evidence proving they
do
not work
st louis
new york
chicago
washington
atlanta
are gun control utopias
and they are plagued with the most
violence
10 more laws
20 more laws
a thousand more
won't make what has already illegal more
wrong or stop criminals from committing
these crimes and y'all are delusional if
you think it's going to keep us safe
i am a walking testimony
of how the criminal justice system and
the gun control laws which is steeped in
racism by the way
have failed the black community
by the age of 25 i had already went to
18 young black men funeral
at the age of 25. i have one black man
in jail
one black man in the grave
and my young grandson gonna be raised
without a
father and it's a curse
on the black community and everyone
else's
something has to change
thoughts and prayers and calls for more
gun control isn't enough
how about letting me defend myself from
evil
i
you don't think that i'm capable
and trustworthy to handle a firearm
you don't think that the second
amendment doesn't apply to people that
look like me
who
and you who are called for more gun
controls are the same ones that are
calling to defund the police
who is supposed to protect us
we must prepare to be our own first
responders
to protect ourselves and our loved ones
i am a legal
law
biden citizen
and i don't need the government to save
me
i teach people how to use a firearm
i empower others to look at me to
understand the second amendment is their
right
i am a proud member of the d.c project
women for gun rights we believe that
education
is the key to safety not ineffective
legislation
we support meaningful solutions
that will actually
save
lives
we support the safe student act h.r
7415
which would immediately make schools
safer
in hindsight of parkland we saw failure
of the government at every level failing
the students
students saw something and they said
something
and the school did not act
police were called to his residence over
30 times and they did not act
and finally the police did not go into
their school that fateful day and fail
to protect those kids
we need to secure our secure our schools
and we got to secure this building or
like y'all do
what's the difference
we call on congress
to ban
gun
free
zones
fun non-partisan firearm education
programs
like kids safe foundation and
non-governmental mental health
organizations like hold my
guns
and in closing i claim that nothing in
these bills do anything to make us safer
or address the mental health crisis in
this country
despite living with the heartache of
losing my son on a daily basis
i believe it is our god-given right
to defend ourselves from any act of
violence
making it more difficult or even more
expensive for me
and people that look like me and other
law abiding citizens will not make us
safer it will embolden the criminals
gun owners are not the enemies in these
gun control policies are not the
solution
thank you thank you
thank you
thank you all for your powerful and
meaningful and
gut-wrenching testimony
we will now
pause
you are excused and we will pause while
we seat the next panel
for their testimony
thanks
so
okay
cheers
okay
meeting will resume
we are now ready for our second panel
and i'd like to introduce our witnesses
the first witness is the honorable eric
adams who is the mayor of the city of
new york
then we will hear from greg jackson who
is the executive director of the
community justice action fund
next we will hear from becky pringle who
is the president of the national
education association
next we will hear from joseph grimalia
who is the police commissioner of
buffalo new york
then we will hear from nick supplina who
is the senior vice president for law and
policy at every town for gun safety
finally we'll hear from amy swearer who
is the legal fellow at the edwin mease
center for legal and judicial studies in
the heritage foundation
the witnesses will be unmuted so that we
may swear them in
please raise your right hands do you
swear to affirm that the testimony you
are about to give is the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth so help
you god yes i do let the record show
that the witnesses answered in the
affirmative
thank you without objection your written
statements will be made part of the
record with that mayor adams you are now
recognized for your testimony thank you
for coming
turn on your mic
thank you thank you very much again i
want to thank you
madam chairwoman
maloney for the invitation to testify
today i also want to thank all the
members of the house committee on
oversight and reform members from the
new york city congressional delegation
and everyone who has testified today
especially those who have so bravely
shared their stories of losing loved
ones to gun violence i was particularly
touched by hearing the husband and wife
that lost their baby girl as a father
with one son
it was extremely impactful to all of us
i am eric adams and i am honored to
appear before you today as the 110th
mayor of the great city of new york to
discuss the ways we can protect public
safety and prevent gun violence
ladies and gentlemen gentlemen it is
high
noon in america
time for every one of us to decide where
we stand
on the issue of gun violence time to
decide if it's more important to protect
the profits of gun manufacturers or the
lives of our children
time to decide if we are going to be a
nation of laws or
confederation of chaos
and we must do it now
it is high noon in america our country
the country i love the clock is ticking
every day every minute towards another
hour of death i'm here today to ask
every one of you and everyone in this
congress to stand with all of us to end
gun violence and protect the lives of
americans we are facing a crisis that is
killing more americans than war
a crisis that is now the number one
cause of death
for our young people
a crisis that is flooding
our cities with the illegal guns faster
than we can take them off the street
the new york city police department has
taken over 3 000 illegal guns off our
streets this year alone but the guns
just keep coming
this is a crisis that transcend party
lines and affects both rural and urban
communities
i know this firsthand as the co-chair of
every town's
non-partisan coalition on mayors against
illegal guns no matter what our party
affiliations we are united in our
mission to stop crime save lives and
bring an end to gun violence because
this isn't about blue
versus red this is about right versus
wrong
whether it is on the street wearing a
badge
or in these chambers
taking a vote we must stand
for what is right first we need congress
to take the handcuffs off the bureau of
alcohol tobacco firearms and explosives
known as atf
and let them do their jobs
that means confirming president biden's
nominee as
soon as possible
we must work together to damn all the
rivers that lead to the sea of violence
common sense gun reform must become the
law of the land
i'm pleased that today the house will
vote on h.r 7910
the protecting our kids act and i urge
swift passage of the gun violence
prevention package for consideration in
the senate i also urge the senate to
pass hr8
the bipartisan background checks act of
2021 and h.r 1446 the enhanced
background checks act of 2021
these are bipartisan gun safety bills
that would make our cities and our
people safer i stand with president joe
biden in calling on congress to act now
to regulate or ban assault weapons in
this country
even if we only raise the age required
to buy one of these weapons lives will
be saved and we need congress to direct
federal aid to localities and states
that support not just law enforcement
and violence prevention but also access
to high quality health care child care
education and housing we must build a
society while youth on a path to
fulfillment
not a road to ruin as mayor my greatest
responsibility is protecting the lives
and the safety of the people of new york
city this is my calling my duty and my
life's work
i did it as a police officer in a
uniform and wearing a badge and i do it
now as the elected leader of our largest
american city but i need your help to
further protect our people and to save
lives the time is act now it's high noon
in america
thank you mr jackson you're now
recognized for your testimony mr jackson
thank you chairwoman uh maloney ranking
member comer and the rest of the
committee for inviting me on this really
important topic
my name is greg jackson i'm the
executive director for the community
justice action fund the only national
gun violence advocacy organization
led by a survivor of color
but i'm not here by choice i'm here by
circumstance
in 2013
just miles from this chamber i was shot
as an innocent bystander
while i was simply walking home
and when i arrived the hospital i wasn't
welcomed with nurses and surgeons no i
was met with investigators they
questioned me as a suspect first and a
patient second
i spent 21 days in the hospital six
months learning how to walk again but
what was most terrifying and tragic was
that when i turned on the tv
i was watching members of congress have
the same debates that we're having right
now
that was nine years ago
every year over a hundred and ten
thousand people are shot or killed by
gun violence
so that means nearly a million lives
have been directly devastated since i
laid in that hospital looked up at that
television and watched the members of
this chamber debate this topic
most of the stories of those who have
been impacted by gun violence like mine
will never make the headlines
you know just two miles from here makaya
wilson was shot 10 years old while going
to get ice cream
karan brown one of my mentees who hosted
his own stop the violence event in his
neighborhood was shot down that same
summer and killed in front of a
mcdonald's
and pamela thomas here in d.c
who was so afraid of gun violence in her
community that she wrote her own eulogy
just to be shot by a straight bullet in
front of her son
these stats are not stats these are
stories of real people
real people that are dying in our
streets every single day
every day 110 americans are killed with
guns and 200 are shot are wounded and
we've talked a lot about this being the
number one cause of death for all youth
surpassing car accidents drug overdoses
and covet 19. but amid this pandemic
we've also seen a 35 increase in
homicides and this still remains the
number one cause of death for black men
the number two cause of death for latino
men and the number two cause of death
for black women
we are here because we cannot and must
not hide from the harsh truth
gun violence is destroying communities
around the country and every day
families experience firsthand the
devastation gunfire brings
to eliminate gun violence we must
swiftly recognize that this is a public
health crisis
that deserves a public health response
at community justice we address gun
violence by focusing on those who have
been most impacted by the crisis and we
urge congress to invest in
community-based solutions that we know
can address those public health risk
factors
that can reduce the risk factors of
those impacted
by gun violence but also address the
root causes but we also strongly
urge that any supply side approach not
only focus on the shooter but on the
supplier and the source of firearms that
are flooding into our communities
in moments of crisis congress has proven
to be as resilient as the american
people and take action
when coronavirus struck our country
congress authorized bipartisan
legislation to provide resources and
regulations to save lives
when ukraine was in crisis
congress sprang into action and
mobilized bipartisan authorization to
authorize immediate aid economic
investments mental health resources and
other services to support those
communities but i'm here to say that we
are in crisis in america today
each time we did the hard thing because
it was the right thing to do and this
crisis is no different
this crisis now has taken away
grandparents
in buffalo
elementary kids
in nevalde
fathers in chicago
mothers in atlanta
nephews in chicago
even pastors in charleston
and we're here still asking for action
there are three direct things that we
know can be done
first we must acknowledge this as a
public health crisis
and craft policies to combat it as such
second we must advance commonsense
legislation that not only addresses the
hardware but promotes community-based
solutions to end gun violence such as
the break the cycle of violence act
and lastly i urge you to create a select
committee on the gun violence crisis to
investigate the health impacts of gun
violence and its disproportionate impact
on black and brown communities across
the country
now is the time to take action before
another person loses their life before
another child opens his last textbook
before another parent hugs that child
for the last time
and also before someone like me
uh isn't alive to ask you to do so
thank you madam chairwoman
thank you miss pringle you are now
recognized for your testimony
good morning
chairwoman maloney ranking member comer
and committee members
i appreciate the opportunity to offer
testimony on behalf of the three
million members of the national
education association
and all devoted educators who teach and
nurture and protect our students
as a teacher with three decades of
experience
i am frustrated
i am heartbroken
i'm angry
that this is where we are
23 years
after columbine
on april 20th 1999
i had been a middle school science
teacher in pennsylvania for 23 years
no experience or training had prepared
me for the questions my middle level
learners asked me
as i joined my fellow teachers in shock
and disbelief
of the carnage that ended the lives of
12 students and one teacher
the only thing that comforted us was the
belief that this society
would never let it happen again
but the list continued to grow
didn't it
virginia tech
sandy hook
marjory stoneman douglas and now rob
elementary
kids were celebrating at the end of a
successful school year
for 19 children and two teachers
it would be the last days
of their lives
these massacres occurring in suburban
urban and rural schools are not isolated
incidents
tallying up
the number of killed or wounded children
does not begin
to tell the full horrific story
camille
a student who survived sandy hook
experienced severe panic attacks for
years
she is one of the more than 311
000 students exposed to gun violence
since columbine
their trauma will likely endure for the
rest of their lives
students across our country
are writing goodbye notes and wills just
in case
unfortunately their fear is perfectly
rational
here in america we are 25 times more
likely to die
by gun than people in other
developed nations so the question we
must ask
is this who we are
is it
our country has already experienced
nearly
240 mass shootings in 2022 alone
but that number does not begin to
capture the scope of this epidemic
every day gun violence kills
111 people that means that we can expect
22
255 more deaths by guns this year
inaction
equals acceptance
of the unacceptable
and this crisis is worse in black and
latino communities where 78 of adults or
their loved ones are victims of gun
violence
the evidence is clear
where there are more guns more people
are killed by guns
single day
the politicians who fail to take action
ignore the majority of americans who
want stricter gun laws
you tell our children
protecting them
matters less
than protecting the status quo
a high school teacher in arlington texas
survived a workplace shooting in
corporate in a corporate setting only to
experience school shootings himself and
countless lockdowns
he is now leaving our profession with
these words
as much as i love teaching i can fully
present represent and protect my
students
i am not going to be the educator they
need
enough with so-called solutions that do
not address the problem
we cannot place enough armed guards at
every school building in america to
protect our babies we cannot ask
educators to carry weapons and wear body
armor while teaching and nurturing our
students
because by the time someone has shown up
with a military weapon it is already too
late
we need for our students
more resources
not more revolvers
you can help us to not only heal
but to hope
pass common sense gun control
legislation so that not one more
community is shattered and not one more
anguished parents like we heard today
has to lay a precious child to rest
our children deserve the chance to grow
and to thrive to live
into their brilliance
thank you for what i know you will do
for our babies
thank
you commissioner
gramalia
you are now recognized
chairman maloney ranking member comer
and distinguished members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to participate in today's hearing i
appear before you today as a police
commissioner in buffalo new york it is
also my privilege to testify on behalf
of the major city chiefs association
we're here today to discuss gun violence
epidemic plaguing our nation
this hearing comes in the aftermath of
multiple mass shootings that have
devastated communities throughout the
country including my home city in
buffalo
our communities are hurting and we must
continue to support them the loved ones
of the victims and our brave first
responders
on may 14 2022
an 18 year old white supremacist invaded
our city and inflicted terror on the
black community in a way never seen in
buffalo's history he legally purchased a
military style weapon and body armor and
then spent months practicing his
shooting skills he entered the top
supermarket and opened fire on civilians
striking 13 and killing 10. he live
streamed this with a gopro he had
affixed to his helmet
retired buffalo police officer aaron
salter jr who i posthumously promoted to
lieutenant and issued the department's
highest honor the medal of honor was
working top security that day
erin was helping an elderly shopper
leave with her groceries when the
shooting began
he did his best to warn customers while
in a completely defensive position he
engaged the shooter as he entered
hitting him with at least one shot
it is often said that a good guy with a
gun will stop a bad guy with a gun aaron
was the good guy and was no match for
what he went up against a legal ar-15
with multiple high-capacity magazines he
had no chance
assault weapons like the ar-15 are known
for three things
how many rounds they fire the speed at
which they fire those rounds and body
count
this radicalized eighteen-year-old adult
should have never been able to have
access to the weapons he used to
perpetrate this attack and the laws need
to be enacted to ensure it never happens
again
buffalo police officers responded the
tops and were able to take the shooter
into custody within minutes i have no
doubt in my mind that their swift
response time and handling of the
situation saved lives i would like to
publicly thank them for and the rest of
the buffalo police department for the
heroism they showed on that day
buffalo is known as the city of good
neighbors we are a resilient culturally
diverse community
we came together after this horrific
tragedy and we will continue to heal
together however no city should have to
go through this
and it is time to make changes to a
system that is leaving blood on the
sidewalks of our communities every day
in 2018 the mcca adopted a firearms
violence policy that would help mitigate
the threat of gun violence without
infringing on the constitutional rights
or re or weakening due process these
reforms include requiring universal
background checks strengthening mixed
definitions and improving access to
records supporting the use of extreme
risk protection orders
aggressively prosecuting straw
purchasers and prohibited possessors and
banning assault weapons and
high-capacity magazines
polling shows the majority of americans
support these common-sense reforms and
congress must act immediately to close
the loopholes in our current system and
the gaps that allow easy access to
military style weapons
events like the buffalo massacre the
shooting in uvalde that took 21 lives
including 19 children and the mass
shootings in laguna woods and tulsa are
the situations that capture headlines
however we must remember that gun
violence epidemic extends well beyond
these events the grim reality is that
shootings have become a daily occurrence
in america's cities emerging trends like
ghost guns and guns modified with
switches continue to pose a challenge
for law enforcement
congress must update our laws to account
for these new threats and carnage that
has accompanied them it will be nearly
impossible to address the gun violence
epidemic without first addressing the
underlying violent crime problem
unfortunately the proactive policing
that helps drive down violent crime has
become a luxury for many departments law
enforcement needs additional resources
to bolster its response to violent crime
an overall lack of accountability for
violent offenders is contributing to
rising gun violence in some major cities
da's are not prosecuting serial firearm
offenders and judges continue to release
offenders on low or no bond to address
these challenges congress must provide
resources for u.s attorneys offices to
support additional federal prosecutions
as appropriate police chiefs see the
horror of gun violence every day members
of congress share our solemn duty to
protect the public the mcca will
continue to call on elected
representatives to eschew politics and
take the necessary steps to address the
gun violence epidemic your leadership is
needed now more than ever
thank you
mr sublina you are now recognized for
your testimony
you want to turn on your mic please
good morning chairwoman maloney ranking
member comer and distinguished members
of the subcommittee
my name is nick ciplina i am senior vice
president for law and policy at every
time for gun safety we're the largest
gun violence prevention organization in
the country
i'm honored to be here today and
grateful for the spotlight you're
shining on america's gun violence crisis
once again we are grieving
frequent public mass shootings terrorize
the country
and are a uniquely american problem
mass shootings often focus
the public's attention and our grief and
with good reason
but they represent a small fraction of
all gun deaths in this country which
include other
homicides suicides and unintentional
shootings
every single day some 110 americans are
killed with a gun and 200 more are
physically wounded
we estimate that one half of all
americans have been touched by gun
violence either directly or someone they
care for in other words we are a nation
of gun violence survivors
to be clear
this burden is not being born equally
talking about our children
guns are now the leading cause of death
for children and teens i'm talking about
people of color black americans
experience 10 times the homicides of
their white counterparts
clearly we're in the middle of a serious
public health crisis
one that is crying out for sensible gun
policy solutions especially at the
federal level
and while gun deaths are hitting
all-time highs the gun industry is
breaking profit records year after year
the gun industry uses fear to sell guns
and it believes that mass shootings are
great for gun sales they are making
money on these tragedies right now
so when we talk about the shootings in
uvalde in buffalo when we talk about the
toll of gun violence on our children
when we talk about the disproportionate
impact on black americans when we talk
about how gun violence costs taxpayers
survivors families employers and
communities 280 billion dollars a year
we need to also
talk about how nine the nine billion
dollar civilian firearms industry is
shielded from the scrutiny and
accountability that has led other
industries to better and safer practices
the gun industry for its part
has innovated not to make guns or us
safer but to make them more dangerous
more likely to evade regulation
more profitable instead of designing
firearms that can't be fired if stolen
or that make it easy for law enforcement
to trace gun makers have created
modifications to mimic automatic fire
they've created impossible to trace
ghost guns that helped circumvent
background checks and they have designed
ar-15s that can be modified in minutes
to bypass the state's assault weapons
law as we saw in buffalo
and now in a crowded field gun
manufacturers are trying to market an
increasingly brazen ways often touting
the deadliness of products glorifying
combat and attempting to peel appeal to
younger and younger audiences
finally let's not forget the industry
has done almost nothing to take steps to
prevent diversion of guns into the
criminal market and to gun traffickers
between 2016 and 2020 over one million
of the industry's firearms were
recovered by law enforcement in
connection to crimes
more and more of these guns carry the
telltale signs that they were purchased
with the intent to traffic or illegally
use them
yet the industry is rarely held
accountable this committee's
investigation found a dealer in georgia
where 10
of the guns it sold ended up on crime
scenes 10 percent
and we wonder why it's so easy for
criminals to get guns
so why is no one holding the gun
industry accountable for its dangerous
practices
in 2005 at the behest of the nra
congress passed the protection of lawful
commerce and arms act which insulates
the industry from most legal threats
and again at the behest of the nra
congress passed the art amendment a
budget rider that purports to limit
sharing of data about guns used in
crimes which keeps the industry out of
the conversa conversation about how
criminals get armed these laws have to
go
in spite of these barriers i'm heartened
that public and private actors in
legislatures city halls courts across
the country are taking action to reveal
the gun industry's role in gun violence
and i'm grateful to this committee's
investigation into gun trafficking and
its recent letters to gun manufacturers
i hope you have the ceos appear here for
testimony because america hears every
day from the families who have lost
loved ones to gun violence and our
country deserves to hear from the ceos
who are profiting off of their loss and
pain thank you
thank you and mrs swearer you are now
recognized for your testimony
madam chairwoman and distinguished
member you're you're mike
madame chairwoman and distinguished
members we still can't hear you turn
your mic on
pull it closer too
is that better
it says it's on it's not on
the green light is on man
i will try to speak a little bit louder
madam chairwoman and distinguished
members of congress
my name is amy swear and i'm a legal
fellow at the heritage foundation where
my scholarship focuses on the second
amendment and gun violence prevention
i've testified before various
legislatures after several mass
shootings parkland virginia beach el
paso and unfortunately too many others
and i hope to god this is the last time
i ever have to testify before a
legislative body after a mass shooting
again
i fear that it won't be
and i fear that it won't be because the
conversation has become predictable
an unspeakably horrific event like
uvalde or buffalo happens reflexively
almost compulsively come calls for
congress to pass a whole host of gun
control measures largely targeting
peaceable law-abiding citizens
should anyone dare question the
constitutionality practicality or even
the effectiveness of any of these
policies their opposition is immediately
framed as callous obstructionism and
their legitimate concerns are brushed
aside as and i quote [ __ ]
any viable alternatives are deemed
frivolous without so much as a passing
thought to their usefulness
and so i will once again run through all
of the problems with syria or the
serious problems with commonly proposed
gun control measures it's all detailed
in my written submission which i hope
you read
semi-automatic rifles are the type of
firearm least often used to commit acts
of gun violence pistol grips and barrel
shrouds don't make them any more or less
deadly in the context of mass shootings
while these while these features can and
do make a difference in the context of
lawful self-defense for civilians which
is why millions of peaceable americans
own them
standard capacity magazines are commonly
possessed by law-abiding citizens for
lawful purposes the few rigorous studies
on their prohibition have found that the
evidence for their success at lowering
rates of gun violence is inconclusive at
best
the context in which mass public
shootings occur
renders magazine limits effectively
useless at saving lives
18 to 20 year olds are legal adults
otherwise endowed with all of the rights
and duties of citizenship including the
right to keep and bear arms
even if it were constitutionally
appropriate to punish a mass of
responsible young adults because a
handful of them committed atrocities the
vast majority of mass public shooters
are 21 or older
and then i'll repeat the same viable
alternatives that would be far more
effective in a far more immediate way
again detailed in the written submission
that i hope you read
take violent crime seriously under
existing federal laws and encourage your
state and local counterparts to do the
same
authorize schools to shift the over 100
billion dollars in unused covert relief
funds to physical security improvements
the hiring of armed trained staff and
the hiring of licensed mental health
professionals
promote responsible gun ownership
without simultaneously imposing
financial burdens on gun owners or
hindering their ability to immediately
respond to violent threats
invest in the nation's mental health
infrastructure to combat the two-thirds
of gun deaths that are suicides
and the list goes on
now congressman i am fully aware that
when you are burying your child
nuanced policy discussions are
irrelevant
it doesn't matter it shouldn't matter to
a fourth grader hiding under her desk
covering herself and her dead
classmate's blood whether the real
problem here is a barrel shroud or the
several dozen missed opportunities to
intervene along the way
but it should matter to you
because you are the ones making public
policy decisions
many of you are the ones implying that a
lot of victims would be alive today but
for a mass shooter's pistol grip and a
background check that he already passed
many of you are the same ones mocking
anybody for quote talking about doors
when a single locked door in uvalde
would likely have saved 21 lives and
when all of us just walked in here today
into this building with its limited
public access points it's one lane one
way locking security doors and its
plethora of armed officers
what happened in uvalde and in buffalo
is horrific it is horrifying no one
should ever have to experience that type
of unfathomable trauma
and i
cannot even begin to imagine what those
families are going through right now
everybody
with a soul has it shattered
over acts like this and we have seen it
shattered every single time from
columbine to parkland to uvalde we did
not somehow this didn't get easier for
us
we did not grow numb somewhere along the
way to the reality of this it's not as
though our family members don't also
teach fourth graders or we don't also
send our kids to school it's not as
though we don't also shop in grocery
stores or go to country music festivals
or work in hospitals as though we don't
also feel the tremendous horrible weight
of these tragedies somewhere deep inside
of our souls because we do
now we oppose these policies precisely
because the lives of these victims
mattered
because
the grief of their loved ones is real
because we all want thriving communities
where families are flourishing instead
of
burying their children
the opposition
has always been and is still today a
genuine concern that these policies
suffer from serious constitutional and
practical defects that they will not
have the impact you promise people they
will
and we have always proposed alternatives
that would be more effective
and less constitutionally suspect
what we have rarely been met with are
open ears
and i hope for the nation's sake that
today is different
because i would really
love to never testify after a mass
shooting again
thank you
thank all of you for your very important
testimony i now recognize myself
for questions
as a mother it is hard to find words to
express
the grief and outrage i feel and others
feel in this room listening to the
stories from our witnesses today
no child should be cut down by a gun
lexi rubio should have been able to grow
up live her dreams become a lawyer major
in math visit australia
eleven-year-old mia should not have been
forced to cower in fear as she watched
her teachers and friends and massacred
and the close-knit vibrant jefferson
avenue community in buffalo many of whom
came today to
stand
with us should not be forced to reckon
with the violent deaths of friends and
loved ones gunned down by a racist with
an assault weapon
we are in a crisis but we are not
powerless
congress just needs to find the courage
to act
and i hope we find it today when we pass
on these sensible and vote on these
sensible gun reform bills let's start
with assault weapons
the shooters in uvalde and buffalo were
too young to buy alcohol
but they were both
purchased assault weapons legally
ms pringle
as an educator your organization
represents millions of teachers some of
whom have witnessed horrific gun
violence some of whom have been murdered
and it's aftermath would banning assault
weapons save the lives of teachers and
students
it absolutely would
there are many other common sense steps
that we can take we can strengthen
background checks raise the minimum wage
age to buy a gun require waiting periods
uh commissioner gramale you are on the
front lines against
gun violence every day in buffalo with
these common sense measures save the
lives of police officers and others in
your community
they absolutely would
mayor adams
new york city already has adopted many
gun safety measures
and you have moved quickly to take
further action
but guns from other states with lacks
gun laws keep flowing into new york
why is it so important that we pass
federal gun safety laws
the as we as we indicated we removed 3
000 guns off our streets but in addition
to that we have witnessed in over
204
increase in what's called ghost guns
if we don't have a combined effort with
of the intervention
items we're putting in place the
prevention and also stop the flow many
of the guns that we're witnessing are
taking a purchase or stolen from outside
our state one gun in particular a
suspect was found with a gun
and was stolen in
july 27 2020 it was used in six acts of
violence
individual cases shooting individuals
shooting into a random crowd the gun
found his way on the streets of new york
so it's more than what we do locally we
need assistance with the partnership of
the federal government to stop the flow
of guns in our cities
other countries have taken common sense
steps to keep guns away from criminals
and they have succeeded in saving
countless lives we stand alone in the
world with the number of mass shootings
and deaths from guns
and as you can see in this chart
the american people overwhelmingly
support gun safety reform
so mr supplina in your view why has
congress
failed to adopt these common-sense
measures that most americans and most
countries in the world have adopted
well to to put it bluntly
chairwoman the gun lobby presents a
formidable obstacle in this country
oftentimes and you've heard it already
today
the second amendment is used as a reason
to not advance common sense gun reforms
even while the court
has not said that the very reforms that
you're proposing uh would violate quite
the opposite the courts have upheld over
and over and over again so the lobby uh
does it's it what it sees as its job to
make every gun law one step closer to
confiscation which is a lie
conspiracies abound about the government
coming to take your guns
and that gets into the head of
well-meaning lawmakers who are afraid
that you know people will believe that
those myths are true they're not true we
can do an awful lot to save american
lives by passing these laws
we we have lost too many lives to gun
violence it's long past time for
congress to act
i now recognize the gentleman from
georgia mr clyde for
mr clyde
thank you chairwoman maloney
and ranking member comer for holding
this hearing today so we can highlight
the need for additional school security
to protect our children i joined the
nation in mourning for the 19 children
and two adults who senselessly lost
their lives due to an evil act
committed about two weeks ago
while every
loss of life is a tragedy no one should
weaponize or politicize these abhorrent
acts to punish law-abiding citizens for
almost 250 years since the founding of
our nation countless hundreds of
thousands of men and women have
sacrificed
their lives to provide the freedoms we
enjoy today indeed those freedoms were
bought at a very high price and must be
guarded continuously so they can be
passed on to future generations if we
allow a motion to drive our actions
actions that have constitutional
constitution altering
consequences we will destroy the very
foundation of our country and break
faith with those who gave everything
that we would be free
evil deeds do not transcend
constitutional rights it's the other way
around constitutional rights are the
ones that transcend evil deeds what
occurred in yuvali and other communities
like sandy hook and parkland was nothing
short of heartbreaking tragedies and
evil deeds heartbreaking and evil for
the loss of innocent life but also
because
from what i have seen in the news about
yuvaldi i believe it was mostly
preventable we don't know all the facts
yet because the investigation is still
ongoing but i hope that this hearing is
truly looking for legitimate functional
and effective answers and not just a
bunch of left-wing talking points to
fill the do something do anything
mentality that i have heard coming from
the biden administration the white house
press secretary ms jean-pierre said on
tuesday may 31st that president biden is
uninterested in pursuing tighter
security at schools in the aftermath of
the uvalde tragedy and i quote
i know there's been conversation about
hardening schools that is not something
that he believes in said miss
jean-pierre one of the things i've
learned during my three overseas tours
of military combat
was that the harder the target you are
the less likely you will be engaged by
the enemy
that's a proven fact and just common
sense that applies across multiple
aspects of life
for that to not be a part of the
administration's focus just shows how
seriously out of touch the democrat
leadership is with reality
you know i want to echo mrs hughes
remarks from the previous panel schools
should be hard targets
violent criminals should never ever have
been able to gain access to the inside
of these schools that means schools
across the nation should implement
sensible security measures like keeping
doors locked a single point of entry
better security technology and a
volunteer force of well-trained and
armed staff in addition to a school
resource officer
and where a school staff
person has additional responsibility
they should receive additional
compensation
a retired military officer from my
district and army colonel sent me an
email a few days ago and i want to read
a short section of it and i quote
i'm absolutely convinced that the single
most effective method to eliminate
school shootings is to take away
all the signs that declare all schools
are gun-free zones and do away with all
laws that require such postings replace
those signs with signs using these words
or similar words we love our children
and will do anything to protect them
accordingly selected teachers and staff
are armed and trained to protect our
children proceed at your own peril you
will be stopped
the rationale for this dramatic change
in policy is really quite simple
gun-free signs gun-free zone signs don't
protect anyone they take away the
law-abiding citizens capability to be a
force in helping to protect the children
and they protect the would-be shooter
because they believe they will be
unopposed from june 1950 through june
2019 94
of mass shootings occurred in gun-free
zones
if a would-be school shooter doesn't
know who is armed and who is not they
would likely move to a more vulnerable
target most potential school shooters
are cowards at heart they do not want to
face a challenge to what they're trying
to do they want to be in control with no
opposition they do not like to be
confronted by someone who would face off
against them because that confrontation
would preclude a school shooter wannabe
from being able to take any unopposed
action
to those who say that teachers or staff
will likely not take up arms to protect
their students
i say they will
there have been too many documented
cases where teachers have heroically
given their lives to protect their
students it's time to give them the
tools and help them protect to better
protect those children so they have a
fighting chance to survive an encounter
with someone who is bent on harming them
and for the record if someone is intent
on harming someone else they will use
whatever is available to do the job be
it a hammer a knife or whatever
there's a lot of insight in the words of
this army colonel he also knows the
difference between a hard target and a
soft easy target and he knows the
advantage of that difference
miss ware you were involved in heritage
foundation school safety initiative
which was developed after the 2018
parkland shooting correct
yes sir in your opinion
what you believe should be done to
secure our schools from violent
criminals to ensure that our students
have a safe place to learn well i think
there are as i mentioned in my testimony
and then again in my written submission
there are several avenues that can be
taken including physical security
improvements you know again it has
become popular to mock people for
talking about doors uh and those sorts
of things but these are basic security
components of the rest of our everyday
lives we see them in apartment complexes
we see them in the building we walked
into today we see them in most corporate
buildings that we walk into in any given
day
um you know in terms of having a quicker
armed response
i i think school should have the
flexibility to decide how that happens
if you look in my written submission in
a footnote there are i'm just from the
last couple of years a good number of
examples and it's just a smattering of
them because i didn't want the footnote
to be 12 pages of armed responses saving
lives whether from school resource
officers or from
including in one case from an armed
staff member who stopped a kidnapping
and then prevented an armed individual
from entering the school where other
children were
and i think again a key component of
this is not just looking at physical
security but also
um you know as plenty of witnesses have
mentioned having the adequate mental
health resources you know we're not
talking about blaming mental illness but
we are talking about when you look at
one what it means the gentleman's time
has expired
i i would i would end by saying looking
at licensed mental health professionals
in schools
thank you very much i yield back the
gentleman from massachusetts mr lynch is
recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chair thank you for
holding the sharing i want to thank the
panel of distinguished witnesses thank
you for coming before this committee to
help us with our work i also want to
thank the previous panel
the families of the victims
who
had the courage and selflessness i think
to
despite their pain
come here
with the sole purpose of preventing
other families from suffering a similar
law so i i thank them
madam share i'd like to ask unanimous
consent to submit for the record
a report and analysis conducted by
koktrong we
alicia
palapiano and margo sanger katz over at
the new york times
it's an analysis of
106 mass shootings since columbine in
this country
and
i want to read an excerpt it describes
best what they found
to quote this report if the key gun
control proposals now being considered
in congress had been lost since 1999
four gunmen younger than 21 would have
been blocked from legally buying the
rifles they used in mass shootings
at least four other assailants
would have been subject to a required
back down background check instead of
slipping through a loophole
ten others might have been unable to
steal their weapons because the efforts
required
to encourage
safer gun storage
and 20 individuals might not have been
allowed to legally purchase the large
capacity magazines that they use to
upgrade their guns helping them to kill
on average 16 people each
taken together those four measures might
have changed the course of at least 35
of those 106 mass shootings a third of
such episodes in the united states since
the massacre at columbine high school in
colorado
that new york times analysis has found
and those 35 shootings killed
446 americans
mr sablina there's been
re referrals made references made to
uh
the fact that someone could cause damage
with a hammer or a knife
i would wonder if if you could talk
about
uh
ar-15 style firearms and and their
ammunition and how different they are
and the greater vulnerability it creates
in in in society you talk about i know
you've written on this in the past and
if you could go over that for a bit just
to educate people who are not familiar
with that type of weapon
so this type of weapon which is derived
from a military style a military weapon
presents increased risk as i believe the
commissioner said earlier
because of their speed
of bullet their handling their ability
to accept high capacity magazines
and they are designed and are advertised
to be able to inflict a mass amount of
damage in a short period of time um they
are also unique in the damage that is
done to the human body when you use one
of these
a a handgun even at a sometimes larger
caliber
won't do the damage to human tissue i'm
not a physician but you did hear from
one earlier who described in great
detail
what a
semi-automatic rifle
with multiple rounds can do so these are
these are unique threats there's a
reason why they are used in mass
shootings because those shooters want to
inflict maximum damage thank you
i do want to add a quote from
a trauma surgeon at the university of
arizona who agrees with your assessment
he said that the damage for an ar-15 on
the body quote
looks like a grenade went off in there
madam chair i am i am so sorrowful uh
for the loss of lexi rubio
and and so many others and and so many
we've heard in in previous mass
shootings that you know i i will support
the package of uh restrictions that we
will consider in the next couple of days
here in congress
to restrict
the
uh use of of assault weapons and
high-capacity magazines and and i'll
vote for the background checks that i
think are necessary
and i respect
my colleagues rights to defend the
second amendment
but i will note when when in defending
the second amendment you you have to go
to military experts and battlefield com
commanders
for advice on how to protect our kids
while they're in school we got a problem
we've got a problem
think about that that you're going to
military battlefield commanders combat
veterans
for advice on how to protect our kids
while they're sitting in school trying
to learn
i just urge my my colleagues to to think
hard on this
and
consider supporting the package of bills
that we have before the congress this
week thank you and i yield back
many yields back the gentleman from
texas mr sessions is now recognized
ma'am chairman thank you very much and i
want to thank the gentleman from
kentucky the ranking member for really
what i think is a thoughtful opportunity
for us
to handle what is a difficult
circumstance i'm a texan and i was about
some hundred miles from uvalde i know
uvalde very well i spent a good bit of
time in san antonio growing up
as soon as i heard about what happened
i immediately went about convening
some ten counties worth of
superintendents mayors county judges
law enforcement people sheriffs deputy
sheriff school resource officers
i did not sit back and wait to find out
what this hearing might develop i did
not wait to find out what someone else
thinks is a good idea i tend to think
that
back home people have the best answers i
say it differently i think texans have
answers for texas problems
madam chairman i do not want to chastise
anybody today i want to thank each of
our people who have showed up
not only from buffalo but from new york
city and others who have taken time to
be here today
i do not wish to challenge anyone but
madam
chairman i would like to enter into the
record
an article from the christian science
monitor weekly june 11th
and also an article which i have
provided to you
from 538 which is a website that they
present information
for the panel
the 538 article said we've known how to
protect prevent a school shooting for
more than 20 years
okay without an objection thank you
madam uh chairman
in fact as i went about looking at this
which i had not previously
i did a good bit of review myself and i
found out that there is the national
center for school safety
it's at the university of michigan in
the school of public health
and they state this
before and still and i quote
the information that we do have access
to these studies seem to be saying that
yes by developing a positive school
climate by educating students on how to
say something
and speak up or find a trusted adult
is having a positive
effect not just on attitudes but also
self-efficiency something we need to
approach
as we talk about behavior
we learned at my meeting that i had in
waco texas
that this is not a decision that these
shooters by and large make that's a snap
judgment
they go about this planning effort and
plan these school shootings out
they happen to people who have become
isolated in school
have been picked on been made fun of
have been bullied and these people go
off into by and large a deep hole where
they are not able to effectively balance
their lives
this is
a public issue problem in our schools
of mental health issues
i go to schools probably every two weeks
and my observations that i have publicly
stated
are that i have seen our schools there
are a lot of children
a lot of young adults
who are
tested in ways where i think they're
reaching out for help
i think one of the things that we should
go to is looking at these studies that
have been out here and i would hope our
schools and our experts that are on
these panels today including you chief
and including you mayor would include
these studies and go back to the schools
and let's identify in our schools
where there is something we can make
better
this article also says a work in
projects
and prod in progress and it talks about
how
talking to students every day
when i grew up we would recite
the pledge of allegiance to the flag
taking a few minutes now i know we've
heard testimony that everything about
america is racist
but i think that in our classrooms we
need to talk about our nations our
rights and our responsibilities but
taking time every day to be nice to each
other
leaving notes knowing each other and
then listening to people who emanate uh
and and identifying people who have
problems it is my hope madam chair woman
and our ranking member that instead of
taking to the floor this immediate
action we would really listen to you
and other experts madam chairman i would
like to see if we would call
justin hines who is director of national
center for school safety assistant
professor at the university of michigan
school of public health
i believe we need professionals who have
studied these things i say this as an
opportunity to each one of you i want to
thank you we listen to you and i hope
you will hear us back thank you very
much and may may god bless the people of
uvalde texas who are struggling through
this at this time and our nation madam
chairman i yield back my time
the gentleman yields back the gentleman
from illinois mr christian marthy is
recognized
thank you madam chair
commissioner grameglia thank you for
your service to the people of buffalo i
was born in india and i immigrated first
to buffalo new york
and so the fact that you said that it's
a city of good neighbors
is very poignant for me
i'm very sorry for the loss of all those
lives in buffalo
the shooter in yuvaldi
used a what
what's called a daniel defense ddm v7 v7
rifle it's a style of ar15 rifle
it markets that rifle as quote a perfect
rifle for everybody
this particular picture comes from their
twitter account on may 16 2022
now commissioner guns are the leading
cause of death among young people aged
24 and under
guns kill far more kids than cigarettes
but we don't let cigarette companies
market to children
sir you don't think it's appropriate for
daniel defense or any manufacturer to
market ar-15 style rifles or handguns or
any other weapons to children correct
i think that picture behind you is very
disturbing is what it is and no i don't
believe that that should be the case and
why do you find that picture disturbing
how many children in our country
because of a lack of safe storage on
weapons have either
accidentally taken their own lives or
somebody else in that household or
another friend within that house who was
there visiting it's it's disturbing
shortly after
the daniel defense rifle was used in the
uvalde shooting
this picture was taken down from their
twitter account and indeed their twitter
account was made private i think they
had second thoughts about advertising in
this manner as well
miss swearer
in 2019 while testifying before the
house judiciary committee
you went viral in a viral video talking
about the lethality of ar-15s you said
quote your mother struggled to hit a
stationary target from six yards out
under ideal conditions and then she
picked up an ar-15 and i watched my
mother put a fist-sized grouping of lead
in the center mass of the target 20
yards out
when accuracy and stopping power matter
they are simply better you said that
correct miss swear yes i did
this is a picture of the 19
children
and two teachers who died in uvalde miss
swear
you mentioned the ar15 stopping power
but i gotta believe
these little children were not the ones
you were talking about stopping correct
no i was talking about stopping the
individual who showed up to shoot them
and the show up to shoot them
who did show up to shoot that individual
was a bunch of law enforcement officers
with an ar-15
and
miss
miss swear your mic's not on but
i can hear you miss swear it's good i
can i can hear miss swear
perhaps perhaps you could switch with mr
subpoena for a minute if his mic is
working
can you please suspend the time the
witness needs to be heard restore the
time please
thank you
congressman can i repeat the question
and then you can say the answer yeah and
if we could just stop the clock for a
minute because we lost some time there
could we change the placards too mr
mr chris morty did you want to repeat
the question yes mr swear when you
talked about the stopping power of these
ar-15s
you it wasn't these children that you
were talking about stopping obviously
no i was referring to individuals like
the one who went into that building and
spent 78 minutes shooting them and i
hope as was the case in uvalde that the
people who show up to stop shooters like
that and these have the ar-15 precisely
for its stopping power and that is
exactly what happened in
in this case
from these pearls this man legally
purchased these arts
and in this particular case the shooter
had legally purchased these ar15 rifles
and was able to stop and obviously end
these lives for forever now commissioner
i want to have i want to address you
again commissioner you know guns are
often
billed as essential to maintaining the
freedoms we enjoy in america
they are an iconic part of america to a
lot of people but cars have long been
central to american life as well
and what we've seen interestingly is
that
here's a picture of
traffic deaths
versus deaths from firearms and at one
time traffic deaths far exceeded
firearms in 1950 but over time traffic
deaths have gone down while firearm
deaths have remained relatively constant
now of course with regard to the right
to bear arms that's in the constitution
but it's not an absolute right that's
why we outlaw machine guns and we
regulate firearms in other ways
sir
with regard to traffic deaths and cars
the imposition
of
rules and regulations and laws
along with private industry adopting
safer ways to drive and
devices to make them safer have led to a
reduction
in traffic deaths but the same cannot be
said for firearms is that isn't that
right
i believe you're correct yes i and
looking at the traffic desks going down
regulations both in vehicle safety
airbags
speed enforcement other things of that
nature have led to safer roads
and what would that
lead you to believe should happen with
regard to firearms
some sensible regulations to
limit the carnage that's happening on
our streets
thank you commissioner
thank you
gentlelady from north carolina ms fox is
recognized for her five minutes of
questioning
thank you mr chairman
the horrific and heartbreaking tragedies
that occurred in uvalde and buffalo have
shaken the nation
we're all made in god's image and i
continue to pray for our society and for
the families of the men and women and
children who were senselessly murdered
we must be thoughtful in how we discuss
and address this issue
when the federal government acts in
haste the room for era is exponentially
compounded this problem should be
diagnosed in its entirety before we
endeavor to place proposals on the table
the simple truth is that top-down
legislative actions from washington do
not provide the state's due deference
they deserve the latitude of the states
to make decisions that best suit their
constituencies must be respected
the second amendment was intended both
to empower individuals and also to
shield them from the federal government
exerting undue influence unfortunately
over time the underlying principle of
the second amendment has been distorted
and misconstrued by washington
bureaucrats who simply want it stripped
away from law-abiding citizens this
cannot be allowed to happen
i now yield the balance of my time to
the gentleman from georgia mr clyde who
has a tremendous amount of experience
with these issues
thank you very much
virginia
um
i would like to ask mr gramaglia
in your sworn testimony you say
of a retired buffalo police officer
aaron salter jr his service weapon was
no match for the military-style weapons
and armor the perpetrator was equipped
with
yet your buffalo police officers
responded to tops a minute after
receiving the 9-1-1 call and were able
to take the shooter into custody within
a minute of arriving at the scene that's
impressive
that's very impressive that your
officers were able to do that and this
gentleman armed with an ar-15 style
rifle
um
what is the office what is the buffalo
officer's standard service weapon a
glock 40 caliber a glock 40 caliber
pistol so they responded with a glock 40
caliber pistol and were able to subdue
this gentleman in one minute
they were able to do that because as he
exited the store he had the
ar-15 pointed up underneath his chin
and then through
what i thought was very calm
de-escalation language
he surrendered his weapon and put it
down had he pointed at the officers we
think we would have a different scenario
here okay but that 40 caliber weapon is
completely capable of stopping someone
with an ar-15 correct
well he had
a military-style body armor and a
tactical helmet on he was shot at least
one time that we had uncovered through
our evidence and that had no effect on
him i
also watched the video both the store
surveillance video that has not been
released and the gopro video that was
downloaded which showed the
confrontation between the 40 caliber
pistol that the officers carry is plenty
enough to stop an armed shooter correct
it's all about shot placement isn't it
it isn't it isn't all right thank you i
appreciate that
mrs swearer
um
actually
um
have mass shootings
or school shootings been carried out
with other weapons other than ar-15s
yes congressman they have okay um what
other weapons and what's the problem
what's the primary weapon if you if you
will
so the primary weapon is actually
plurality are handguns alone um another
you know sort of larger segment are
several variations of firearms some
combination of rifles handgun shotguns
and then a smaller percentage are rifles
alone
okay thank you very much
so handguns um
are are still
very very potent firearms
madam chairwoman i would like to
introduce this article
into the record and i request unanimous
consent it's a fox news article may the
28th 2022
and it's entitled west virginia woman
with pistol shoots kills man at
graduation party saves several lives
without objection all right thank you
you know
what happened in yuvaldi was an
incredible tragedy
and it had a very terrible ending
but something very similar happened
uh the very next day that wednesday in
charleston west virginia
and
a particular woman in west virginia
fatally shot a man who had begun firing
an ar-15 rifle into a crowd of dozens
the woman was attending a west virginia
party she drew her pistol and fired on
the convicted felon
no one at the party was injured
and the gentleman
obtains his weapon illegally
criminals will obtain their weapons
however they want
they will get them illegally
more gun laws are not going to stop that
not in any way shape or form because
criminals simply do not obey the law
the gentleman's time has expired madame
i'd like to ask permission to
insert into the record an article why do
something won't work
from the wall street journal thursday
june 2nd 2022. thank you without
objection
the gentleman from virginia mr conley is
now recognized i thank the chair and i
thank our witnesses for being here today
i was the chairman of fairfax county
when the virginia tech massacre occurred
at that point in american history that
was the worst gun massacre in our
history
i buried
six young children
students
that week
six
i'm still in touch with many of the
families years later
and the emptiness in their hearts and
souls
cannot be filled
it is
a tragedy that lives with them forever
those children were killed by a mentally
ill person
who should not have had access
to weapons
but did
he wasn't a criminal he was mentally ill
we hear excuse after excuse
that gun laws don't work
the australian experience would suggest
otherwise
after a series of massacres in that
country
australia
adopted some strict gun laws
they don't have the massacres weekly we
do
it changed
behavior
because
it changed access to weapons and
ammunition
we've heard the answer is arm our
teachers
that would be the solutions
miss pringle
you deal with teachers
would that be a good solution from your
point of view
absolutely not
we
know that the
majority of not only our teachers but
our parents
do not believe that arming teachers
would in any way prevent the carnage
that we have seen
for over 23 years
i just want you to imagine
i was a middle school teacher
my responsibility was to ensure that
every student was nurtured and that they
could learn come to school ready to
learn every day
and now
the suggestion that i as a teacher
would be responsible for carrying a
weapon
and making a split decision swift moment
decision about whether i was going to
shoot someone
or not
whether that responsibility
would be mine to bear
that is a distraction
from what we know we need to do in this
country which is to pass
comprehensive
gun control laws something we have never
done in the short time that we did ban
assault rifles assault weapons we saw
that carnage go down didn't we yes we
did but we've never
passed comprehensive
gun legislation in this country thank
you you need to do it now
mayor adams welcome
mayor adams you're the mayor of i think
the largest city in the united states
yes would it be a good idea from your
point of view as the mayor of that city
and your commitment to reducing crime in
that city
to arm our teachers in all of your
schools in new york city would that be a
solution from your point of view no and
i think the facts show that between 1996
to 2010 one study found
that police officers were three times
more likely to die from gun violence
with a heavy flow of guns in their city
so it's harmful to the law enforcement
community it's harmful to our civilians
and it's harmful to our children
mr
grandma julia
police commissioner
would arming teachers help your force
would it have made a difference in your
community in buffalo i think what we
have to be careful on is to not
militarize our schools and make students
feel like they are in a a
you know a system where they are
surrounded by
weapons in an institution where they're
supposed to be learning i certainly
agree with that hardening our targets
making sure our schools are safe
buildings having a strong school
resource program where school resource
officers are engaging with their
students are building trust within their
students
but i think we have to you know caution
against
over weaponizing our schools
uh it's uh it causes fear in our
students and i think we need to engage
our students in these conversations and
and just real quickly and ms pringle's
point the use of weapons and the
decision to use them for law enforcement
could be a split-second
judgment and that requires careful
training does it not
it's a considerable amount of training
for absolute split second decisions that
are second guessed for
years on thank you i yield back
the gentleman yields back the gentleman
from georgia mr heiss is recognized for
five minutes mr heiss thank you madam
chair uh just for the records from what
i can
research and understand there are some
300 000 or so crimes committed every
year of violent crimes in which guns are
a part of
the situation there are between 500 000
and 3 million incidences a year where
guns prevent
violent crimes from taking place so
let's
clarify here the issue is not gun
violence guns
are not the issue we have a people
violence problems who misuse guns
and other means whenever
they intend to harm
individuals and the answer to this
situation
when you have violent people the answer
is not defunding the police the answer
is not
pitting one group of americans against
another which we see far too often
these days the answer is not
ignoring the rule of law
the answer is not releasing criminals
into our streets or allowing them into
our country
the answer is not a lack of consequences
for those who commit crimes and being
soft
on crime for those who commit violent
crimes we have got to look at the
problem which is violent people
and at some point in this country we've
got to recognize that there is great
value
in upholding the rule of law
we've got to recognize and teach that
there is a such thing as moral absolutes
not the least of which is respecting
one another
respecting life
we've got to in the midst of this
conversation
i believe embrace religious
beliefs look there there are there are
risks
that come
with a free society we all understand
that
but we have a moral and a spiritual
crisis
in this country right now and that is
reflected in violent people
that we see more and more
but it is impossible for us to have
a system of government which we have in
this country where we have
limited government and maximum freedom
if we do not have a citizenry that is
capable of self-governing their own
lives with an authentic understanding of
right and wrong
and so for us to take out of the
equation
any mention
of
moral absolutes or the role that our
founders
mentioned and described as indispensable
supports to our system of government
which is morality religion and morality
then i believe we're making a mistake in
all of this discussion
these things cannot be ignored mayor
adams
let me real quickly begin with you and
if we can go quickly
new york city is certainly one of the
leading examples of gun restrictions and
gun restrictive measures in the united
states yes or no
uh
your mic was off yes
yes and yet we all know new york has
continued in recent years to see a rise
in crime yes or no
yes
okay in january of this year you
released a in a press statement
regarding your blueprint to end gun
violence in new york city
you had in that a quote that that says
this it is illegal to carry a gun in our
city yet police officers take them off
the streets every day in record numbers
you made that statement correct oh yeah
i said many comes from georgia right
and and so here we still
have
in a city that has the great
greatest among the greatest gun
restriction laws in the country a rise
in crime
and
guns being carried off the streets in
record numbers every day
it doesn't appear that
the attempts
that are
produced by the gun restrictions are
having any effect of keeping bad people
from getting guns and
taking taking the constitutional rights
away from
american citizens
only helps criminals is i guess what i'm
getting to
miss where let me come to you
if if we continue down this path of
restricting gun rights from american
citizens
making it easier
for criminals to have targets knowing
that there will not be guns by legal
citizens there to defend themselves what
kind of impact will that have
in the long run
first i want to make sure that is my
bike still not on
it
can we put a pause
use your neighbor's mic use your
neighbor's mic maybe that'll work better
my my apologies i was told the issue had
been uh taken care of
uh congressman to answer your question
criminals are rational actors um you
know you look at the studies on this and
the way in which criminals operate um
obviously they don't want to confront
someone with a firearm
any more than you know we would want to
if we were criminals they are rational
actors um you know you mentioned the
statistics statistics on defensive gun
uses um i think that is important to
point out um i would also note you know
how much lower that it
is
considering there are a number of states
that essentially
do not allow ordinary law-abiding
citizens to protect themselves with
firearms in public and or who make it
far more difficult
for individuals to
keep and bear arms even inside their own
homes and so that could be considerably
higher under different circumstances um
you know that said again i appreciate
you pointing that out um but again
criminals are rational actors to pretend
otherwise is is
borderline silly um so of course
gentleman's time has expired okay thank
you thank you madam chair the gentleman
from maryland mr raskin is now
recognized
thank you madam chair
buffalo uvalde
sandy hook tree of life mother emanuel
church el paso
walmart pulse nightclub las vegas
columbine the bloodbath continues
in the history of our species
a number of civilizations have practiced
or allowed human sacrifice including the
sacrifice of children
the carthaginians the mesopotamians the
incas the aztecs
will we be recorded as such a society
that accepts the sacrifice of innocence
gun violence is the number one cause of
death of children in the united states
of america today
which makes us globally unique
we have rates of gun violence and gun
death 20 times higher than other
industrialized nations like france the
united kingdom israel norway sweden
japan
no other nation comes close to what we
see here
even though we have comparable levels of
mental health problems
and mental illness
will we continue to accept the slaughter
of innocence including innocent children
as acceptable collateral damage for
loyalty to a completely
bogus and distorted misreading of the
second amendment and what the supreme
court has said about it
justice scalia in the heller decision
was emphatic that reasonable gun safety
regulation is perfectly consistent with
the second amendment rights
justice scalia said
he specifically rejected the view
advanced by a number of our colleagues
today
saying that the right of gun ownership
is not unlimited no just scalia stated
the second amendment right is quote not
a right to keep and carry any weapon
whatsoever in any manner whatsoever and
for whatever purpose
he
enumerated a partial list of reasonable
regulations including a ban on carrying
concealed weapons the possession of
firearms by felons
the mentally ill and other dangerous
people
laws forbidding the carrying of firearms
into schools in government buildings and
other public places laws imposing the
conditions and qualifications on the
sale of firearms such as background
checks all
all of these things
he said are perfectly consistent with
the second amendment right
it's not different from other rights we
have like the first amendment where you
have an absolute right to speak but you
don't have a right to set up a
demonstration with loud speaker system
in front of the white house at two
o'clock in the morning and keep the
president's family up we accept
reasonable time place manner regulations
with respect to all rights
now
our colleagues invite us to believe the
second amendment is some kind of policy
straight jacket but they won't read or
quote the decision by justice scalia
himself
who wrote the most elaborate defense and
explication of the majority's view of
the second amendment in dc versus heller
in
2008.
mr suplina in 2005 congress gave the gun
industry
unprecedented and unique immunity from
civil lawsuits for crimes committed with
their products no other industries got
anything like that could you explain
what that immunity protection means for
the gun industry and how it has blocked
common sense laws to end gun violence in
our country
yes congressman thank you uh the the law
placa uh which you cite has given near
blanket immunity to the gun industry and
the result has really had a profound
impact on what we know about the gun
industry's role in gun violence as well
as any accountability uh for
the industry so acts that would have led
to either litigation that would have
exposed
truths like happened with the tobacco
industry or accountability like happened
in the automobile industry safety
practices that would have improved at
these manufacturers because there was a
risk of doing nothing just simply does
not exist with the gun industry
what reckless marketing uh and sales
practices has the gun industry engaged
in because of this blanket of immunity
that has been bestowed upon them well
you know the there are several uh and
the marketing is getting increasingly
reckless and increasingly desperate as
the field gets more crowded uh but also
in terms of distribution practices i've
heard several times today about how easy
it is for criminals to get guns as if
that's some active magic but these guns
are all starting with gun manufacturers
and gun sellers
we are we know that certain gun
manufacturers are fueling gun shops that
are selling disproportionately into
illegal markets and the gun industry is
is protected by placa because they're
saying oh we're following the law well
the numbers speak for themselves
okay and then finally um chief
you were interrupted before what do you
make of this claim
that we shouldn't have laws governing
for example a universal criminal
background check because criminals don't
follow the law is that an argument
against having any law against murder
rape assault because criminals by
definition don't follow the law
the gentleman's time is expired but the
gentleman may answer
so the universal background checks is a
simple process that's going to have
those that want to legally obtain their
guns with their constitutional rights to
obtain those guns criminals absolutely
are not going to follow that but the
more guns that we keep flooding in
without background checks without uh
proper uh
adherence to get those guns uh through
straw purchases and other manners that's
how we're flooding the market so that
criminals can obtain those guns and
justice scalia emphasizes
the gentleman from texas mr fallon is
now recognized thank you madam chair you
know we hold up hearings on all sorts of
topics for all sorts of reasons
sometimes for political reasons or even
worse sometimes for political theater
aimed at
attaining political currency currency
which will then be spent on winning an
upcoming election
other times hearings are held to
actually solve a problem
we're here today because of the
tragedies in buffalo and the horrific
loss of life in my home state of texas
and yavaldi which a beautiful american
community ripped apart by a troubled and
evil coward now when lives are lost and
innocence is stolen particularly when
children are the victims it's natural to
want to assess and focus blame
who did this and and how did this happen
and i'm no different than any american
i'm heartbroken and i'm furious those
innocent children are gone and the
indescribable suffering of the families
is beyond
words
we have a president that says
continually that he must do something we
must do something many democrats are
echoing that we must do something no we
need to do something effective that will
keep our children safer as i mentioned
when a senseless tragedy like this
happens blame's thrown around some
people want to blame guns some people
want to blame gun manufacturers some
people want to blame believe it or not
the constitution some people want to
blame an entire political party and all
this couldn't be more misplaced
the shooter is the only one
to blame
so when the president and many democrats
are claiming that guns are the problem
and the readily available supply is the
culprit
well the more guns in america the
argument goes the more dangerous america
becomes america becomes but the actual
facts belie this thinking in 1969 so
about 50 years ago there were 180
million firearms in this country today
it's about double
2019 is about 365 million yet the murder
rate back then was
nine point six four hundred thousand the
murder right now is five or in 2019
anyway it was five per hundred thousand
so twice the number of guns and yet
murder rate was cut in half the truth is
that guns have always been readily
available in this country but mass
shootings and in particularly mass
shootings of schools were non-existent
or at least extremely rare until they
became a grisly recent phenomena
so what's changed in the last 50 years
there's been a noticeable breakdown of
the family there's been an erosion of
faith and there's been a seismic drop
in social interactions in large measure
due to the overuse of these dang
smartphones and the proliferation of
social media which is probably better
described as anti-social media
senseless mass shootings are not
committed by well-adjusted successful
socially polished people
they're committed by disturbed unstable
courts
by the end of the year so
we
can i get my time back
yes thank you
rule out what we don't want
thank
you senseless mass shootings are
committed by unstable disturbed loaners
with mental disease refusing to address
better mental health services especially
for young people
is to do a disservice at best and it's a
dereliction of duty at worst
the focus sadly by the democrats is to
restrict guns or prohibit their legal
possession entirely a democratic member
of congress in a committee hearing
just recently said and i quote we will
not rest until we have taken weapons of
war out of circulation in our
communities so
do restrictive gun laws or prohibitions
work the most dangerous nations on the
planet according to the world bank in
the u.n are el salvador jamaica
venezuela and honduras
and what else do they have in common
it's also nearly impossible for an
average citizen to own a firearm and yet
they are terribly perilous places to be
believe it or not some
democratic-controlled cities in our
country with restrictive gun laws are
even more dangerous than the
aforementioned countries st louis has a
higher murder rate than el salvador
baltimore does as well and detroit is a
more lethal and dangerous place to go
and visit or live than venezuela
so does passing prohibitions i mean it
just simply doesn't work doing something
doesn't work doing something effective
is the path that we should and must take
history has shown us when you disarm
law-abiding citizens you create not more
safety but more peril
the inconvenient truth for some on this
committee and in this chamber is that
more firearms in the hands of law
abiding citizens make us all safer so
let's talk some real solutions we must
harden our schools with controlled
access and single point of entry with a
tiered entry procedures the main office
should be located directly by the front
door which is single access entry
classroom doors should automatically
shut and lock like hotel room doors do
let's support and foster a robust
marshall school marshall program where
qualified and volunteer teachers and
staff go through proper training to be
armed on campus let's increase the
number of sros in our schools let's
leverage technology by putting cameras
in schools much like frisco texas did 15
years ago when i was on a city council
and they had a command center and a
mobile command center and any threat
could be immediately detected tracked
and eliminated forthwith we need a rapid
response plan and rapid response forced
to be trained to world class standards
and also law enforcement doctrine must
change so when there is a threat the
schools aren't besieged but rather our
heroes in blue advance hone using honed
techniques and teamwork and technology
and eliminate the threat as soon as
possible our goal should be to protect
our children
no parent
educator citizen legislature or nation
has a higher calling let's look at real
and effective solutions and shelve the
divisive rhetoric
because american children deserve
nothing less thank you madam jeremiah
thank you uh the gentleman from
california mr rokhan is now recognized
thank you madam chair
like so many on this committee and
around the country
i was
deeply moved
not as a politician as a father by the
testimony this morning of the families
of victims
kimberly rubio
who lost her precious daughter lexi
cut through all the talking points all
the debate and asked the central
question before
our congress and our country
and she put it what do we value more
children
or our guns
it's really that simple
i want to talk about the common sense
reforms on guns but as a representative
of silicon valley i feel i also have a
duty to talk about
some of the role of social media
in this
massacre
with the yuvaldi shooter on instagram
having a group chat
where there is conversation of school
shootings
where there's conversation
of
threats of violence where he's bragging
about getting assault weapons
why is there no action and let's be very
clear these are minors he was a minor
when he did this it's not the same free
speech rights
mr sublina do you think companies like
instagram
should have some responsibility
in group chats when minors are involved
and you have explicit discussion of
school shootings
to do something
i think the role of social media
companies is an important one and and
you're right to point it out congressman
uh
instagram facebook these are often where
we see the earliest warning signs of a
potential mass shooter
as well as other social media platforms
where these instances are discussed
there's often multiple people in the
chat
and i do want to also mention uh with
respect to the buffalo shooter for
instance
he cited youtube for the videos that
allowed him to modify
the firearm that he had to accept a
detachable magazines which he used to
deadly effect so social media companies
do have a role to play here and just
like my colleague mr raskin said that
the right of the second amendment is not
absolute it's important to recognize
that the right of the first amendment is
not absolute under brandenburg you can't
have things that incite violence and
there are greater protections for minors
i mean it is crazy to me that you can
have people under 18
talking about
shootings and mass shootings and these
companies are taking no action so we
need to have regulation that gets to the
heart of this
you know mrs swear i'm trying to
understand your position and i just want
to ask you some simple yes or no
questions to understand where you're
coming from
is it your view that someone who has
committed a violent felony should be
able to purchase a gun yes or no no
is it your view that someone who's a
serial rapist should be able to purchase
a gun yes or no
very clearly no is it your view that
someone who is a drug trafficker should
be able to purchase a gun yes or no no
and these are becoming insulting and so
well i mean so would you support any
laws that would make sure that violent
felons serial rapists or people who are
drug traffickers will not get access to
guns if they are written narrowly
tailored to approach that issue without
burdening the rights of law-abiding
citizens or criminalizing low-risk
transfers between responsible citizens
yes i'm more than willing to look at
that law that is exactly what the
background checks because right now what
you have a case is that the background
checks do not cover
a lot of the sales to violent felons to
serial rapists and i just want to be
clear when the republican party their
position right now by opposing h.r 8 is
they are for violent felons serial rape
is still being able to purchase these
guns no they're not yes they are they
are not they're aggressive
i'm reclaiming my time this is the point
of order madam chair the violent the
position of republicans is that violent
criminals be in jail well no the
position is madam chair the gentleman
has not stated a valid point of order
the the the position hr8 all hr8 at its
core said is that violent felons are
still getting these guns serial rapists
are still getting this guns and the law
and order party that that that has
demagogued the issue of law enforcement
and policing that party is saying we're
okay with violent felons still getting
these guns we're okay with serial
rapists still getting these lines and
all the congress on the democratic side
is trying to do is to close those
loopholes i will say that are you to my
testimony on this very bill before the
senate judge last year
she kept interrupting me okay all right
but then
the gentleman from pennsylvania mr
keller is now recognized
um
i would first like to take a moment to
thank all our panelists uh this panel on
the previous panel for your testimony
we've seen some horrific acts in the
commonwealth of pennsylvania
we saw a devastating shooting in
philadelphia on saturday
and i continue
and we all should offer prayer for the
families
across the commonwealth of pennsylvania
and across our nation
that have been affected by these acts
committed by violent criminals
skyrocketing crime in our cities that's
what we
we need if we need to focus on new york
city saw a 16.2 percent increase in
violent criminals
shooting others in march of 2022
that's up from a year before
san francisco saw a 31 percent
rise in homicides
in chicago
violent criminals were responsible for
shooting 47 people on memorial day
weekend alone
there's a trend here
crime is rising in cities that have the
most restrictive laws on firearms and
have the least severe criminal
enforcement penalties on the books
and in fact
cities that don't enforce the laws that
are on the books
the district attorney in san francisco
has dismissed over 40 percent of felony
convictions since 2020
and in philadelphia homicides have
increased
58 percent
during district attorney larry krasner's
tenure
however only 21 percent of crimes when
violent criminals shot another person
since 2015 have led to criminal charges
and less than one tenth of those
incidents resulted in convictions
philadelphia police are making record
amounts of arrests for crimes committed
by violent people with guns
yet krasner's office has dismissed or
withdrawn
more violent cases every year
he has been in office
the bottom line is when you fail to
enforce the law
and hold criminals accountable
you get criminal behavior
so miss swearer
how does failure to prosecute past or
current crime affect crime rates in the
future
well it it certainly emboldens criminals
and reasonably allows them to believe
that there's a very little chance that
they will be punished or in any way held
accountable for their crimes
many of the proposals we're discussing
today are widely implemented across the
municipalities where crime spikes are
happening would limiting law abiding
citizens right to own a firearm curb
these disturbing trends
no it would not and i would also point
out the reality of most gun violence is
not that it's being perpetrated by
people who lawfully purchase and possess
their firearms it is largely perpetrated
by individuals with long histories of
violence
who obtain their firearms already
through illegal and illegitimate
channels that are not addressed by
universal background checks because they
are already circumventing the law
regarding
those background checks so it's a very
low reward endeavor even if it's like
100 enforceable okay what measures
should be taken to ensure victims and
their families are not legally ignored
in favor of defendants
i would again refer to some of my
previous testaments and i know our time
is short previous testimony that i've
given before the senate judiciary
committee on gun violence in chicago i
think a lot of that is still
applicable to your question um
from a federal perspective as i said
continue to enforce federal laws
and hold criminals accountable at a
federal level when possible and
encourage state and local counterparts
some of whom
have done a horrific job of this to do
the same
so i just have a question there's
there's a call to the nix system
and when you purchase a firearm as i
don't know how many people in this room
have ever have ever gone through a
background check
but it does ask questions i know it was
brought up earlier
about criminals
being able to purchase guns is it not
already illegal for rapists
and and murderers and people have done
domestic violence and convicted of these
things isn't already illegal for them to
purchase firearms uh to purchase and to
possess assuming they are felons and
have not had their rights restored to
them under existing state or federal
processes though there is no process
under federal law so it would just be
under the state okay but but the point
is it's already we're not saying that
criminals should have laws we're saying
criminals should be put in jail
and law abiding citizens should be
allowed to to
lawfully possess firearms that is
certainly what i'm saying and that is my
understanding of what every member who
has opposed hr8 is saying as well
thank you and i yield back
gentleman yields back the gentleman from
maryland mr fumey is recognized for five
minutes
thank you very much uh
madam chair there's a old saying that
your
pain is where your passion is and so let
me just go back
to where we started almost uh three
hours ago at the beginning of this
hearing
and talk for a second about the pain
that i felt
as i hope many of you did listening
firsthand to the accounts of
witnesses and victims from uvalde and
from buffalo
listening to them
i am still stunned and
heartbroken the gun carnage that
continues in schools
in supermarkets in movie theaters
in churches
on the streets of my baltimore and the
streets of cities all over
this country is across
ladies and gentlemen that we all
bear whether we want to
or not
the gun laws that we hope will be passed
today i hope are seen as a beginning
not the end
only as a beginning otherwise
i really believe that we are doomed in
our fight against murderers and their
guns and the evil and the pain that they
spread
i
want to acknowledge and thank the
gentleman from louisiana mr higgins
the commissioner from buffalo and the
mayor of new york all of whom
served in law enforcement and saw
firsthand
how difficult it is to deal with the
violence perpetrated by guns
and particularly assault weapons
and i want to associate my remarks with
those of mayor adams when he said
let the atf do its job in rounding up
so many illegal guns that are on our
streets and to finally confirm a nominee
madam speaker
madam chair
you'll remember 1994 we were members of
this body we worked for a whole year
a whole year
to put together and pass an assault
weapons
ban
and the only reason it wasn't permanent
was because we weren't able to get
enough
people
members
on the other side of the aisle
unfortunately to go along with that and
so the compromise was a 10 year ban on
assault weapons which expired in 2004.
i'm just shocked that 18 years has gone
by and this body has not moved
to re-establish that
in 1999 as a
president of the naacp
i filed suit against the gun industry
took us three years
to get to court because the nra did
everything they could
to keep it from not happening
and finally in 2003
we went to court i testified in brooklyn
new york for over a week
but we didn't have the weight we needed
and the nra was a bigger force
than we could deal with
and so we lost that but the judge to his
credit said this does not prohibit the
fact that there certainly will be other
lawsuits like this
the nra heard those words
and took them to heart and spent the
next 18 months putting in place an
absolute immunity on the gun industry
and unfortunately was able to get this
congress to pass it and signed into law
it is just unbelievable that we will get
absolute immunity to any industry in
this country particularly when there's
harm
and personal
injury
so i um
i think more than anything else i was
stunned a little while ago in hearing
the gentleman my colleague on the other
side of the owl
saying that he had sought out
advice from a military commander about
how to protect
schools and that the advice was
harden the target
and miss swear when you were asked to
comment on that you said absolutely
harden
the target
well that's fine
except how do you harden
a supermarket
how do you harden
a church
how do you find a way to go out
and harden movie theaters
if the only answer is hardening the
target we've already capitulated
and i'm telling you i'm so glad that so
many people are focused on this hearing
around the country so they can see
firsthand what is going on here
we have a problem that is not going to
go away
every year it gets worse and so until we
are prepared
to do what we were sworn
constitutionally to do
to protect this country from enemies
foreign and domestic
we would have failed
madam chair i yield back
the gentleman yields back the gentleman
from louisiana mr higgins is now
recognized mr higgins thank you madam
chair commissioner maglia
looking at your your
presented statement sir
so you support confiscating guns from
individuals determined to be a threat to
themselves or others determined to be
so by this legislation my colleagues are
putting forth
my understanding of the of the letter of
that law
which i one thousand percent oppose
as what i found in fathers the letter
that i lost an anonymous tip
from a citizen so if this was law
commissioner
would you confiscate would you go to
your neighbor's home and confiscate
his legally owned weapons a man that was
not under criminal investigation nor
under arrest
would you do it
the red flag laws
would that's a yes or no brother i got
five minutes to make an hour and a half
statement here it's more than a yes or
no answer we'll move on
if you can if you cannot say yes you
would confiscate weapons
from an american citizen that was
subject to this law that my colleagues
intend to push through this congress
then you and you said in your statement
that you would confiscate those weapons
if an american was determined to be your
quote a threat to themselves or others
according to that law determined to be
is defined by an anonymous tip
that an american citizen a threat to
themselves or other you're a police
commissioner a thin blue line brother
sworn uphold the constitution and you're
saying you'd seize those weapons i see
that as a problem i'ma bring us back in
time
to world war ii
america's population 140 million
15 million american men came home from
world war ii
with deep scars
and significant skills
they bore the invisible wounds of war
and there was weapons everywhere
i want to talk about
mental challenge
my father was one of those men who was a
navy pilot in world war ii he came back
from the war and built his family
on the seventh of his eight children i
was born in 1961
we had guns everywhere there was
virtually no regulation any child in the
50s could buy a weapon from any seller
if daddy sent them with the money
we didn't have mass shootings
it wasn't until 1968 in america that
serial numbers were even required
on weapons sold in this country
you order weapons to the sears catalog
by the mail
in 19
in the 70s i attended a high school
large rural school virtually every
vehicle in the parking lot was a pickup
truck and almost everyone had a rifle
law shotgun on the back glass and a
pistol and under the seat
and we didn't have school shootings
1979 i began college
one of the jobs i had to work my way
through college
was as a carpenter
we restored historical buildings
we had to determine in the process of
that work what was the original cuts of
these these homes residential homes
built 75 85 100 years ago
you could tell by the saw cut if it was
a
mechanical cut an electric cut or hand
cut
by such observations we knew
exactly how that house was originally
built
until my amazement as a young man
beginning college in louisiana working
to my amazement you know what i
discovered madame chair you know what
these houses did not have that were
built a hundred years ago in cities in
america you know what they did not have
commissioner
lox
lox
now i ask you all
what happened to that country man
a country where homes were built in
cities with no locks
a country where guns were everywhere and
virtually not regulated at all
where millions of americans 14 million
americans came back it's 11 percent of
the population at the time after world
war ii with incredible skills of war and
weapons of war as you called them
everywhere but we didn't have mass
shootings
and here we sit today
where an entire once proud
democratic party is presenting
unbelievably unconstitutional laws
to press upon our nation and we have a
police commissioner
that says he would go home to home and
confiscate legally owned weapons
if he got a tip
madam chair
i yield my speech but i will not yield
my opposition to these unconstitutional
laws the gentleman's time has expired
the gentlelady from new york ms
ocasio-cortez is recognized thank you
madam chairwoman and thank you to all of
our witnesses here today i apologize if
i go quickly we've just got five minutes
and a lot of work to do
let's talk facts here there was a lot of
discussion about new york city there is
no discussion about gun violence in new
york city without discussing the iron
pipeline that is florida georgia south
carolina north carolina virginia
pennsylvania an honorary mention to ohio
where 70 percent of likely illegal
traffic guns found in new york city come
from
there's no discussion about gun violence
in chicago without talking about indiana
because the violence and the mothers
that we have to comfort
are losing children due to the guns and
the carnage on the lawlessness unleashed
by those states i move on every week in
recent memory we have had at least one
mass shooting
miss pringle you are the president of
the national education
association you represent teachers
um
between 2009 and 2018
how many school shootings did the united
states have
288 208
now let's look globally our g7 partners
canada france germany italy japan and
the united kingdom combined how many did
those countries how many school
shootings did those countries have
five fifty times more in 10 almost 10
years
288 versus 5.
this is not
normal
not only is it not normal it is
internationally embarrassing and
delegitimizing to the united states
because for all the billions and
trillions that this body authorizes in
the name of national security we can't
even keep our kids safe from their
schools being turned into a war zone
now let's talk about why let's talk
about one thing
more important to lobbyists and the gun
industry than children than houses of
faith than human beings let's talk about
profit
mr suplina
in 2020 22.8 million guns were sold
reflecting a 64 increase from 2019
correct
correct in one year
and across the board gun manufacturers
and ammunition companies began to see
record profits is that right
that's correct
now let's put in that into context
in 2020 again
more than 45 000 americans died by
gunfire reflecting an almost three-fold
increase from 2015 are those statistics
correct that's accurate
so in your view are you seeing a
correlation between gun profits and gun
deaths in the united states
yes
this is about blood money
between 2019 and 2021 two years leading
gun manufacturer sturm and ruger saw
gross profits double to almost 280
million dollars
in fact during an earnings call their
ceo called the sales boom quote historic
ferocious and that the future was bright
a month after that an ar
556 pistol murdered 10 people at a
supermarket in boulder colorado those
profit margins 280 million dollars
went
go
to lobbying is that correct much of that
goes to lobbying correct
significant amounts go to lobbying
correct and can you remind us what the
gun industry is lobbying against when it
deploys these uh lobbying resources
they are lobbying against
every law that would regulate firearms
period
and can you uh briefly tell us how gum
companies have poured extra profits
directly into lobbying against gun
reform and as an advocate in this space
uh what have you seen just name rattle
off some of the measures that they have
just a few that they have
lobbied against lobbied against they've
lobbied against background checks which
uh on all gun sales which would in fact
as was mentioned earlier allow for the
would-be criminal to obtain a firearm
from a law-abiding citizen without a
background check the criminal would be
breaking the law but we could stop that
they've lobbied against red flag laws
which would temporarily deprive after
due process
firearm from somebody who's opposes a
threat to their selves or others that is
a court adjudication thank you
everything thank you very much and for
context
the nra spent about 250 million dollars
in 2020 alone that's more than twice the
entire salary of congress combined
in one year lobbying against gun safety
laws
there's
also this discussion about
anything but a gun but that these are
about violent people but yet we aren't
doing anything about addressing the
actual root causes of misogyny where
two-thirds of mass shootings are
connected to domestic violence or the
emergence of white supremacy
radicalization mass incarceration and
poverty and the connections between that
and mass shootings in our communities i
yield my time thank you madam chair the
gentlelady's time has expired the
gentleman from wisconsin mr grothman is
recognized for five minutes thank you
very much uh last couple weeks i had a
chance to go down to mexico and they
brought up an issue that i wasn't really
expecting to hear
but a couple of border patrol guys
pointed out to me
that
that firearms were
very very regulated in mexico and you do
a little google search and you find out
the recent article in the wall street
journal the first came out of the six
first six or first nine months
uh in 2019 mexico with some wildly
difficult laws
had a murder rate of six times that in
the united states not six percent more
not 60 percent more but assuming he got
it right maybe he was chair picking the
year i don't know six times as many
murders as in the united states
i assume
the mexican officials who put these laws
into effect
thought they were going to save lives at
the time that they made it so difficult
for law-abiding mexicans to get a hold
of a firearm but obviously the results
of their laws was not to make mexico
safer there are
thousands probably tens of thousands of
people
who have died now in mexico under the
current
rules connected to
ownership of guns
we've also in this country had a
dramatic increase in the number of
deaths from guns the last two years
since kind of the beginning or at least
expansion of the i hate police movement
which i blame for all the
young people and not so young people who
have
died in the last two years in this
massive increase of murders that we've
seen almost unprecedented uh first of
all i'd like uh mrs swear
to comment a little bit on on that
mexican statistic and comment on the
dramatic increase
in the number of uh
homicides in this country in the last
two years not because it's easier to own
guns but kind of because rhetoric a lot
of the rhetoric coming out of this
building uh this anti-police rhetoric
congressman i will respectfully refrain
from commenting on the the statistics
you pointed out from mexico i'm i'm not
overly familiar uh with any of the
underlying causes i i will you know to
the greater point say mexico is to my
awareness one of the only other
countries in the world with a right to
quote keep and bear arms um which is
sort of a misnomer in that country as
you
point out um so it's fundamentally
different understanding
of what that means than clearly in our
country um as to i'm sorry please remind
me of the the second aspect well the
massive increase in murders in this
country in the last year like i i think
it's it's hard to pin that down to any
like one simplistic notion of what is
causing that uh certainly i think
um
problems with policing and cause to
defund the police loss of uh trust
between communities and and police
members that all plays a role as i i
pointed out in
my written submission but i think it's a
number of things yeah i'll give you
another question then um this week i'll
be reintroducing something called the
student and teacher safety act which
will allow schools to use existing
grants they have
meant in part for improving school
conditions and learning to improve or
boost
school safety following the uvalde
shooting white house press secretary the
white house press secretary said that
president biden does not believe in
hardening schools to provide more
security resources or law enforcement
officers
if these measures can be effective in
preventing another mass shooting why do
you think the president is not open
to hardening schools this way
i cannot read the president's mind but
my guess is he would rather focus on
other ways of addressing it i'd also
very quickly like to point out um to
reference something congressman fumey
said uh to seem to infer that we only
care about or have only mentioned one
aspect of a greater issue which is
focusing on physical security
congressman i respectfully don't know if
you were not here for my opening
statement or have not read my written
submission but i respectfully have
pointed out roughly a dozen other issues
as well this is comprehensive in nature
it is not one thing or the other it is
both i've been here for three hours
since before the hearing started i heard
your testimony my reference was to
schools and my reminder was thousands i
think he's out there is not recognized
well witness addressed me madam chair
okay
could you give me another few seconds
back someone jumped in there
um
well could you give us if
if president biden is going to stand
between
us and trying to improve the physical
security in school districts can you
give us other ideas that we can use to
prevent these tragedies
sure as i mentioned in both my written
and oral testimony i think we can focus
very clearly on
building up the nation's mental health
infrastructure both specifically in
schools and generally across the board
we are talking about two-thirds of gun
deaths every year that are suicides
which is clearly plays into an aspect of
mental health which is problematic we
are talking about with mass shootings
individuals who clearly
show signs of being a danger to
themselves or others but who are
otherwise you know not felons yet and
oftentimes cannot be involuntarily
civilly committed so looking at you know
targeted interventions with adequate
means of due process
and also just behavioral risk assessment
you know we've talked about instagram
and threats on instagram what's
concerning to me is that so many people
saw so many signs especially in uvalde
and it appears that nobody reported them
or knew to report them or knew how to
report them or didn't think anything
would be done about it
and that gentleman's time has expired
okay the the gentlelady from california
ms porter is now recognized
miss swear in 2019 you testified on
representative sicilini's bill the
assault weapons ban before congress
at the 2019 hearing representative jim
jordan asked you if law-abiding people
will be less safe to protect themselves
if that bill was passed do you remember
your response
i have a general idea of what i would
have said under that circumstance but no
i don't remember my specific words you
said and i quote
i think worse than that sir you will see
millions of otherwise law-abiding
citizens
become
felons overnight yes for nothing more
than having scary-looking features on
firearms
i was quite surprised by your answer you
read the bill before you came to
congress to testify against it yes
if we are referring to the ban on
assault weapons correct yes so you knew
that the bill would allow
any gun owner
to maintain possession of any
semi-automatic assault weapon that was
lawfully possessed before the bill
became law
no so that is the case under that bill
the problem is anytime that is
transferred to anybody else
i don't care if you please restrict the
witness that the time belongs to me
if you don't want to hear an answer to
my question i'm not trying to
ask
the gentlelady has reclaimed her time
so you knew that the bill you said yes
in response to my question that you knew
the bill would allow the gun owner to
maintain possession of any
semi-automatic
assault weapon that was lawfully
possessed before the bill becomes law i
swear i respect that we have different
opinions on representative cicilline's
assault weapons law but we cannot have
different facts
we have a duty to debate the merits of
proposal you falsely testified under
oath would you like the explanation no i
will not i have not yielded
suspend
madam chair if she's going to ask
questions shouldn't she let the witness
have time to the gentleman is not
recognized
you falsely testified under oath your
point of order point of order
what is the gentleman's point i've been
accused of falsely testifying and i
would like to address it the gentlewoman
has accused her of perjury
is she going to hold to that or are you
going to allow the witness to respond to
that accusation of of criminal conduct
you have not come forward with a a
significant point of water
miss porter will continue
i asked you if that bill was correct if
the bill would allow any gun owner to
maintain possession and you said yes yet
you testified that the bill would allow
people to become felons overnight
earlier today you testified that you
hoped that this was the last time you
testify before congress for the sake of
our nation and the integrity of this
congress
after a mass shooting trying to figure
out how to solve a problem that we are
all heavily invested in
solving a
how dare you reclaiming my time
how dare you
mistake
the law how dare you legislation that
you do not even want an answer to
miss swear i'm moving on
i'm a lifelong consumer protection
advocate from 2015 to 2020 there were at
least 2070 unintentional shootings by
children 765
of those children died a consumer
product that causes this much harm to
the public would normally be subject to
a recall but federal law prohibits the
consumer product safety commission the
agency responsible for protecting the
public from dangerous products from
regulating guns
this is absurd after one child died
using a peloton treadmill last year the
consumer product safety commission
intervened and recalled the product
but when hundreds of children die using
guns there is no federal response there
is no federal safety standard for guns
even though 40 000 americans hurt or
kill themselves or other people in
hundreds of accidents every year
instead of regulating guns like any
other consumer product federal law
protects gun manufacturers
a teenager can watch a video online and
learn how to modify a rifle to make it
more deadly and the gun industry avoids
any liability if that teenager uses that
modified rifle to fire repeatedly and
rapidly at innocent people even though
their products could be designed
to prevent unsafe modifications i want
to give an example in 2001 a 13 year old
boy named billy accidentally shot his
father's handgun and killed his friend
josh
billy mistakenly thought the gun was
unloaded because he had removed the
gun's magazine
josh's family sued the gun manufacturer
for failing to warn billy and other
consumers that their product could be
fired without a magazine
it's a simple case it should have been
decided by a jury as is provided under
the constitution instead because of the
gun industry's immunity the gun
manufacturer was able to dismiss the
case without a trial
if a pharmaceutical company failed to
warn customers about the known risks of
one of their drugs they could face
thousands of lawsuits but we allow the
gun industry to sell weapons without
taking any precautions to protect
children and families from fatal
accidents
mr suprema do you think the gun industry
would do more to protect children if
congress ended their immunity
absolutely would ending the gun
industries immunity put gun
manufacturers out of business
no it would not in the 1990s lawsuits
force big tobacco to pay for the harm
they caused by manufacturing cigarettes
just last year big pharma agreed to pay
26 billion for communities devastated by
opioids
of gun violence also deserve their day
in court they deserve justice
i yield back the gentleladies times
madame travis parliamentary inquiry
general ladies and gentlemen chair madam
chair point of order madam chair point
of order
uh
again
miss porter accused our witness of
perjury that's a very serious accusation
accuser of lying madam chairs the
gentleman has not stated a property i'm
stating against
[Music]
a witness of perjury
the gentleman is not stating a proper
point of order usually
order accomplished
thank you all for being here
thank you madam chair and obviously this
is a
tragedy that's heartbreaking for all of
us uh and naturally
coming out of this as we look for
solutions
emotions are naturally high because
we're all grieved by the fact that we
see this in our nation
there's going to be a thousand
reasons why why we're asking
and the investigations are ongoing
obviously
some answers of course will never
even the conclusions we could come up
with will of course never answer
the cry of a parent who's lost a child
and i think any of us who who have
children
can understand that our hearts just
break for what we've seen
as we move forward we have to continue
to to figure out
how we propose solutions that actually
create solutions very often in this
congress
we do things out of a best of intent and
have the worst of results and
a lot of data there's a
lot of data that points to the fact that
gun
control
leads
not to more safer communities but
to more dangerous communities
for example one of the proposals out
there right now is to raise
the age of being able to own a rifle and
in our federal society we have many
states and so we're able to kind of test
these things out and as far as i know
the only peer-reviewed article
study that's been done on that it was in
the journal of law and economics
talked about it and looked at it and and
said if anything there was a six percent
increase
from states who began to implement age
requirements or raised age requirements
so we have to
tread passionately but very carefully as
we continue to put
addresses from a policy perspective
i'd like to bring up
a topic that i think needs to be added
to this conversation and and uh
representative heiss and higgins touched
on this quite a bit
because a lot of times here in congress
we'll measure
politicians like to get away with
measuring our personal compassion
usually it's it's on a spending bill so
we'll we'll measure our personal
compassion by how much money of other
people's money we spend and and
generally it's the more money we spend
the more compassion we have in a sense
i've always found that absurd
in the same way as we do this
it would be wrong for us just out of the
sake of doing something to measure our
personal compassion by how much of other
people's constitutional rights we take
from them and give to the federal
government and it's important to point
out in history that anytime a federal
government
takes authority it's always for
altruistic reasons uh the the danger
comes when the next person in charge is
or
or what happens after that and and me
and many times that that power is taken
under good intentions uh and then used
nefariously uh much much later um so we
have to be very careful about that we
have to keep history and context in mind
and all of this and the other thing i
would say is that we should not think
that that any of this is monocausal this
there's not one thing that caused this
there's a lot of things but one thing
i'd like to throw
into the mix of this because if there's
a common denominator as we look across
these it's not age so much it's not the
firearm used or the type or even how it
was required
as much as it is we see when we look at
crime
in our communities when we look at the
societal decline we we are in decline as
a nation when it comes to the moral and
societal decline in our nation there
there's no doubt about it um and
and
one of the biggest
factors that is a common denominator
across much of this is simply broken
homes father fatherlessness
a doj study from the journal of research
in crime and delinquency reports that
the most reliable indicator of violent
crime in the community is the proportion
of fatherless homes
a 2019 meta study
in the journal of psychology crime and
law found that growing up in
single-parent families is associated
with elevated risk of involvement in
crime by adolescence
a 2019 study from the pew research
center finds that the u.s has the
world's highest rate of children living
in single-parent households
national fatherhood
are
the national fatherhood initiative has
compiled some data and and it's people
from adolescents from fatherless homes
are more likely to commit crime they're
more likely to end up in prisons they're
more likely uh
to to to end up in in poverty and so we
have to figure out for a long time our
government has subsidized even and
promoted policies that continue to break
down the home
and uh we have to do what we can to make
sure we come back to this and i would
just like to give whatever time remains
to miss swear to to address the perjury
charges that have been made against you
the gentleman's time has expired oh my
apparently the gentlelady from florida
ms wasserman schultz is now recognized
thank you madam madam chair
gun manufacturers didn't always market
weapons of war to civilians and until
recently trade shows didn't make
military style guns available to the
general public
now gun makers aggressively market ar-15
style weapons to civilians and actively
tie them to military and law enforcement
weapons smith wesson america's largest
gun manufacturer even developed a name
for this marketing ploy calling it the
quote halo effect
now i want to draw your attention to the
screen
mr suplina i want to ask you about one
advertisement that i find troubling this
one
this is an ad for a daniel defense mk 18
a high speed military military-style ar
similar to the daniel defense ar used at
the robb elementary school shooting in
uvalde
the ad states quote use what they use
and that the gun features quote military
adopted technology mr suplina do you
believe the associations made in this
advertisement are appropriate for a
civilian
no but they're very effective at selling
military-style weapons to the civilian
population
reports on this gun indicate that it's
favored by special forces i would like
to ask daniel defense why the same style
guns being used in war zones should be
marketed to everyday people
it is clear
who gun makers are marketing to fred
guttenberg lost his 14 year old daughter
jamie in the marjory stoneman douglas
high school massacre in my own community
fred filed an ftc complaint alleging
that smith and wesson mimicked
first-person shooter video games in its
advertising materials to attract
adolescents and young adults smith and
wesson's m p 15 223 caliber rifle was
used in the parkland massacre mr suplino
what level of culpability should gun
manufacturers have when they market
human killing machines to a civilian
customer base again this this is now
unfortunately increasingly the norm
among gun manufacturers to market using
you know video game style ads daniel
defense itself referenced popular video
games and it's advertising in its
advertisements
and they should be held accountable for
this
thank you um commissioner gramelgia i'd
like to turn to you next um i want to
put another advertisement on the screen
this is an advertisement for a
bushmaster xm15
is that the same gun that was used in
the mass shooting at the top supermarket
on may 14th yes it was
this advertisement shows a soldier with
a bushmaster and it states quote
versatility on the range or during
patrol your officers were actually on
patrol that day and many of them
responded to the active shooter scene
with far less advanced weaponry how do
you prepare officers to protect
themselves and the public from
military-grade killing machines every
day i know it was referenced that you
know it's no no problem uh that that
they had you know adequate uh weapons to
be able to defend themselves but is that
the case
against this weapon no we have uh active
shooter vest that we have in our patrol
cars um you can't wear them on a regular
basis they're far too heavy it's
something that you'd have to grab
and put on if you have the time to do it
thank you president pringle i want to
turn to you you've worked closely with
teachers and students for years on
combating gun violence without
meaningful gun reform students are
forced to practice mass shooting drills
just this week and i know we stood
together yesterday and you heard me talk
about the high school students from my
children's high school alma mater to
mark the success of their fundraising
drive to put stop the bleed kits in
every classroom on that high school in
that high school campus
i mean those those are kits that are
meant to triage a bleeding wound
students now prep for the time that they
have
that they have in school
in the event that they are
facing an active shooter and that they
may bleed to death from from gunshot
wounds what kind of traumatic effect
does normalizing gun violence do these
reactive measures have on students
we have seen over the years an increase
in
[Music]
anxiety an increase in the number of
students who are seeking additional
assistance from our mental health
professionals we are seeing an increase
in the amount of students who are coming
to our schools with all kinds of social
and emotional learning gaps because they
have been subjected to overly aggressive
drills and
looking at social media and tv and
seeing other students suffer and die at
the hands of gun violence
marketing mass killing machines to a
civilian customer base by using imagery
and words that suggest that the purpose
that that's the purpose of their product
is gross and immoral but it's just what
gun companies do now in order to profit
from a market beyond their older male
customer base the second amendment does
not absolve gun manufacturers their
responsibility to market their products
responsibly and children should not be
doing fundraisers for stop the bleed
kits instead of making sure that they
can have a fun prom doing car washes
bakings
having bake sales to make sure that
their life on campus as students is is
improved as opposed to their life on
campus doesn't end
and they have to use a stop the bleed
kit that they've raised money for yeah
the gen lady's time has expired
as previously was stated at the
beginning of the hearing mayor adams has
a hard stop at 1 30. mayor adams thank
you so much for joining us here today
and for your testimony and for your
service you are excused thank you so
much thank you very much
to biggs is now recognized
mr biggs thank you madam chair you know
last week i thought i'd heard it all
when one of the democrats threatened to
end the filibuster
wanted to pack the supreme court
and said they would confiscate guns in
order to do that
they would they would
basically emasculate the senate as an
institution
and also
emasculate the supreme court as well i
thought that was interesting was pretty
bad but then we have here someone
actually accusing a witness and actually
taking out of context
a witness who testified previously and
accusing her of a purge of perjury
following that though but i got to tell
you the most egregious thing that the
democrats did today
is they took a person
a young person little mia
who was traumatized
two weeks ago
still suffering under
obvious ptsd as she testified in that
video
and bringing
that poor little girl to relive this and
if we're going to hear about how
traumatic and i don't say they're not
dramatic these raising money force stop
the bleed kits is
then it's particularly pernicious and
outrageous to take an 11 year old child
who graphically described how she spread
a classmate's blood upon her
and feigned her own death
to make her relive that
if we're talking about ptsd
you just prolonged
the agony of that little child for what
for your own political gain your own
political purpose that is despicable
and over the course of more than nine
hours last week my colleagues on the
judiciary committee my democrat
colleagues made it clear that they don't
believe any americans should have access
to the means to protect themselves and
their families democrats opposed a
republican amendment that would allow
victims of domestic violence to purchase
firearms they opposed a republican
amendment that would allow the spouses
of active duty and deployed military to
purchase firearms and
again they promote promoted ending the
filibuster packing the supreme court and
confiscating guns from law abiding
citizens
and they gave their entire game away by
making clear that neither congress nor
the supreme court will stand in the way
of their radical mission
their proposed solutions to the problem
of violent crime in this country is to
make felons of out of law-abiding
citizens under the age of 21 to make
felons of law-abiding citizens who own
firearms in homes with children and to
make felons of law-abiding citizens who
own or purchase magazines that hold more
than 10 rounds of ammunition
the most common fire in this country
so sells 15 round magazines their
proposed solutions are to force law
enforcement officers to ignore due
process and to strip law-abiding
citizens in the means to protect
themselves and their families from
threats and make no mistakes my
democratic colleagues intend on total
infringement on america's second
amendment rights miss swearer before you
answer the the most pertinent question i
think that we're going to hear from you
in just a second i want you to tell me
can you define defensive use
uh defensive use and i'm assuming you
mean lawful defensive defensiveness
would be a use of a firearm that is to
defend oneself lawfully against criminal
actions by another
how often is lawful defensive use of
firearms in this country according to a
2013 report by the cdc uh almost all
with
very few exceptions but the most
rigorous studies and almost all of them
show that it's somewhere between 500 000
and 3 million times a year i think it's
roughly probably around an average of a
million myself do you believe the
firearm used for self-defense defense of
others or for the protection of property
saves lives
yes it objectively saves lives
now
you were accused
by someone who took out of context
something you testified in 2019
of effectively committing a crime and
committing perjury before congress would
you please like to respond to that
congressman respectfully i appreciate
the opportunity but we've wasted enough
time on political gains today and i'd
like to get back to the merits of
actually talking about solutions very
good
now i'm going to go forward now and and
madam chair i'm going to submit
please uh
the following uh items for the record
the testimony of stephen williford
before the senate judiciary committee on
may 25 2021 mr williford is a good guy
with a gun who heroically confronted and
stopped a mass shooter in sutherland sp
springs texas i also submit a 2019 study
by john lott of the crime research
prevention center his study examines
data on the rate of shootings and
accidents in schools that allow teachers
to carry farms which found zero cases of
someone being wounded or killed from a
shooting let alone a public mass
shooting at a school that allows
teachers to carry firearms and thirdly
an article by the washington examiner
that the buffalo shooter was an
eco-socialist racist who hated fox news
and ben shapiro without a yield back
without objection the gentleman yields
back the gentleman from georgia mr
johnson is now recognized and we have
been called for votes so after him we
will
recess
thank you madam chair for holding this
hearing and i'd like to thank the
witnesses particularly those on the
first panel for their testimony i was
very moved by what each of them had to
say
americans have grown weary frustrated
and frightened by the ever intensifying
cascade of gun violence afflicting our
country
and they are sick and tired of their
elected leaders
continuing to do nothing to address the
carnage
the fact of the matter is that the gun
lobby led by the nra and the gun
manufacturers that funded
exert great influence on politicians to
support its policy which is that the
only way to stop a bad guy with a gun
is a good guy with a gun
you know i mean if if that holds true
then
you know
it just doesn't make sense in a
civilized society and i'd submit to you
that
every person with a gun
makes us
unsafe as opposed to
uh more secure
um this every stopping a bad guy with uh
with a good guy with a gun just has not
worked
to
to
allow the floodgates to remain open for
gun dealers to flood our streets with
weapons that are more powerful than what
was available last week
uh that policy madam chair has been a
deadly failure
and if we continue the unbridled flow of
firearms flooding our nation's streets
we will continue to see rising rates of
gun violence in america
no other country has a problem like the
gun violence problem plaguing our
country
and policy makers who stand in the way
of doing something to address the
problem should be ashamed of themselves
and they need to be voted out of office
and replaced with leaders who are
willing to stand up to the nra
and pass common sense gun reform laws
it's common sense to impose a ban on the
manufacture and sale to the public of
military assault weapons meant for use
on the battlefield
it's common sense to mandate universal
background checks by closing the gun
show loophole
and it's common sense to raise the age
to purchase all firearms from 18 to 21
but for some reason my colleagues insist
on doing nothing to reverse
what is a tide of of a failed policy
it allows greedy firearms manufacturers
to maintain their ever-growing profits
by flooding our streets with weapons of
war and they continue to
ignore the impact of their inaction
hiding behind the second amendment as if
it were the bible
they proclaim
any attempt to pass gun safety
legislation infringes on their right to
carry
well what about the right to live
of the 19 children and two chief two
teachers killed in uvalde the
10 shoppers killed in buffalo new york
what about their right to live
what about the right to live of the
almost countless others who've died from
street gun violence
how much more blood should be shed
before we in congress take action
madam chair the house has acted to pass
laws on universal background checks but
our legislation is stalled in the senate
because of the filibuster
and congress today
will pass common sense gun legislation i
should say democrats in congress will
pass
common sense gun law
uh today and pass it on to the senate
where it will be met with the filibuster
the overwhelming majority of americans
support the types of common sense gun
safety reforms under consideration
this week
and failure to act is unconscionable
failure is an insult to the countless
dead children and shattered families and
communities
failure is an insult to the people we
are here to represent and i join my
colleagues in their fervent thoughts and
prayers
and beg
my colleagues to match their thoughts
and prayers with equally fervent action
mr
gramalgulia a paper released by the
international association of chiefs of
police noted that when the biden assault
weapons ban was in place between 1994
and 2004
the number of assault weapons traced to
crimes fell by a dramatic 66 percent
since assault weapons often used against
police officers and the iacp is
supportive of the assault weapons ban or
the assault rifle ban what message does
it send when republicans who loudly
proclaim their support for law
enforcement refuse to even discuss
banning assault weapons
you know my issue here is that we need
to reduce the amount of
bloodshed on our streets and the damage
that these weapons cause
will lead to more bloodshed on the
streets it's more victims that are being
struck
and it's
something that needs to be banned
thank you
gentlemen's time has expired the
gentleman from florida mr donalds is
recognized for five minutes thank you
madam chair and madam chair also thank
you for the indulgence before we have to
go vote um heard a lot today don't want
to do too much speechifying because we
do that too often here uh miss ware it
was just it's been referenced a lot
today actually about the need for
universal background checks and closing
the quote-unquote gun show loophole can
you actually explain in detail what that
policy actually means
sure so universal background checks
start with this this general conception
of
what could be united at its core
legitimate um right now the only
sorry most gun sales uh whether it's
brick and mortar gun stores whether it's
a bought over the internet anything that
occurs inter state
those require a background check under
existing law the only exception is for
intra-state sales between private
sellers and that is largely because they
do not have access to the next system
they cannot like ffl's call up the fbi
and say hey can you run a background
check um
now
could that theoretically be a way that
that interstate sale for individuals who
are otherwise prohibited to obtain
firearms sure as i point out
the problems with hr8 and all of those
other bills is that this is a low reward
endeavor this is already not how most
criminals are obtaining their firearms
they are already obtaining them through
the black market through informal
channels that are not in any way shape
or form addressed by interstate private
sales and on top of that things like hr8
would criminalize a whole host of
responsible temporary low-risk transfers
between law-abiding citizens like if
your buddy wants to borrow your hunting
rifle um or you know you're going on a
month-long trip to europe and you want
your guns to be secured and your friends
safe next door you'd have to go through
a background check legally transfer
title of your guns to that individual
and then legally transfer title back to
yourself when you're done um so that's
the problem some swear real quick so the
policy of universal background checks
would that have stopped the shooter and
udalavi from acquiring his weapon it
would not have stopped the shooter and
it would have stopped the shooter in
parkland from acquiring his weapon it
would not have stopped with perhaps one
lone exception a single mass public
shooter in the last 20 years because
they all either passed or were capable
of passing background checks and that's
the problem the shooter and the shooter
in sandy hook the the new the newtown
shooting did that shooter kill his
mother and take the guns yes he did and
i think i i forget his age but he
otherwise did not have a disqualifying
history the shooter in ivaldi did he
actually shoot his grandmother in the
face before he went to perpetrate the
crimes in uvalde to my knowledge yes
folks here's the deal one of the things
that we've seen through all these mass
shootings i was a member of the state
legislature during the parkland shooting
so i was in the legislature during that
time period the one thing is crystal
clear that these mass shooters that
target our schools are all psychopaths
they are psychotic
in parkland the red flags were there for
everybody to see the school district did
not act that came out in the parkland
report the the site itself was not
secured that came out in the parkland
report in yavaldi the back door was open
it was open wide open
the the perpetrator shot his grandmother
in the face
that is insane
um i know in this bill the proposed
build uh today or tomorrow they're
talking about raising a gun raising the
age to buy rifles from
18 to 21. are we now going to say that a
19 year old who is a legal adult in the
united states does not have the mental
capacity to own a shotgun or an ar-15
but they have the mental capacity to
enlist in the military they have the
mental capacity to actually sign legal
contracts they have the mental capacity
to be treated as an adult by law
enforcement and they also have the
mental capacity to vote in the united
states but they don't have the mental
capacity to own a shotgun or to own a
rifle and not inflict harm on their
fellow man
you look like look man i got three sons
two of them are school age now when
these shootings occur
man they
they hurt me because i could only
imagine what it is as a parent i'm a
parent
but i also understand that i have a
responsibility as a legislator to
actually
defend the constitution of the united
states
the constitution the second amendment is
there it is our responsibility to defend
it and if we look at the data from the
mass shootings that have occurred in the
united states over the last 20 years the
one constant especially when it comes to
schools
is that these shooters
are young
they are mentally disturbed
and the vast majority of people who are
in their age group would not even think
or go down the pathway of committing
these atrocities
we don't pass laws
because
of the quote unquote
one or two psychopaths we only pass laws
in order to maintain the actual legal
momentum of freedom in the united states
the second amendment is not there to
stop psychopaths let's be perfectly
honest with it it is not that's not its
purpose
the purpose of the second amendment is
clear it is to protect the
constitutional rights of american
citizens
these shootings are awful
they're awful
but the data is clear about how how to
find the people that actually do this
and the measures put in front of us
would not have actually stopped these
shootings i'll yield back the
gentleman's times expired votes have
been called to allow members to vote the
committee will stand in recess until the
end of the first vote series the
committee stands in recess
okay
okay
is
it's like
let's let's leave in today
yes
um
now